programming throwdown episode 77 julia take it away Welcome, everyone, to episode 77. You know, we have a lot of discussions with people and emailing in who aren't in university anymore or are thinking about what to study. And the question always comes up about, you know, kind of the importance of computer science in the, I don't know, maybe it's not the classical term, but how I always thought about computer science. And that would be relative to just programming or software engineering, which I don't keep up on the kind of subtleties of all the different words. And I know we've probably talked about the differences back and forth several times on the show. But what I mean here is the things you would find in a textbook like data structures and algorithms. Pick your favorite.
Programming Throwdown 第 77 期，Julia，开始吧。欢迎大家收听第 77 期节目。你知道，我们经常和一些人讨论，或者收到一些邮件，他们已经不在大学读书了，或者正在考虑该学些什么。大家总是会问到计算机科学的重要性，我不知道这算不算是一个经典的术语，但我一直以来是怎么看待计算机科学的呢？那就是相对于单纯的编程或软件工程而言，我并没有跟上所有这些不同词汇的细微差别。我知道我们可能在节目中反复讨论过它们之间的区别。但我这里所指的，是你会在教科书里找到的内容，比如数据结构和算法。选你最喜欢的一本吧。
Yeah, I mean, it's like, you know, computer science 101, right? You sort a list 10 different ways and you build a tree and et cetera, et cetera. And the thing I want to point out is that even if you're going to, you know, go to some sort of bootcamp, if you're watching online courses, learning how to code a website,
是啊，我的意思是，这就像是计算机科学 101，对吧？你用 10 种不同的方法对列表进行排序，然后构建一棵树，等等等等。我想指出的是，即使你要去参加某种训练营，或者在看在线课程，学习如何编写网站代码，
I mean, these things are awesome. And actually, the mechanics of using an IDE, you know, telling a computer what to do, how programs work, all that is important. And I'm also a huge proponent of understanding, actually, architecturally, how computers work. For me, that's a big help in the work I do about getting programs to run and to run quickly and debugging when there's problems, especially in languages like C++ or C where you can have, you know, need to be careful about how you use your memory. But what the classic computer science I want to talk about is that there's a lot of work done in academia and understanding problems and thinking about things, things like NP complete, P versus NP. What are the problems there?
我的意思是，这些东西都很棒。实际上，使用 IDE 的技巧，告诉计算机该做什么，程序是如何工作的，所有这些都很重要。而且我还是一个坚定的支持者，认为应该从架构上理解计算机是如何工作的。对我来说，这对我所做的工作有很大帮助，比如让程序运行起来、快速运行，以及在出现问题时进行调试，特别是在 C++ 或 C 这样的语言中，你需要小心使用内存。但我想要谈论的经典计算机科学，是指学术界在理解问题和思考事物方面做了大量工作，比如 NP 完全问题、P 对 NP 问题。这些问题是什么？
What are all the kinds of things that you maybe read blurbs about in your textbook or come across and you kind of file them away in your head for later? And what I ran across this week, an instance of this, and I was thinking about it that, wow, I had never really used the techniques I'm going to talk about in a minute before. But, you know, having come across them by keeping abreast of the like world of computer science, even though in my day to day, we always talk about this, how that tech companies love giving interviews where they ask you about like absurd doubly linked list manipulation.
还有你在教科书中读到过简介，或者偶然遇到并把它们存放在脑子里以备后用的各种事情。我这周就遇到了一个这样的例子，我当时在想，哇，我以前从来没有真正使用过我一会儿要谈论的这些技术。但是，通过关注计算机科学领域，即使在我的日常生活中，我们总是谈论科技公司喜欢在面试中问你一些荒谬的双向链表操作。
You're like, yeah, that never do that in my real, real job. And this weird math that you think you need to learn. And in reality, you're never going to use it. And those are mostly true, but it does come up.
你会觉得，是的，我在现实工作中从来没做过那个。还有那些你以为需要学习的奇怪数学。实际上，你永远不会用到它们。这些大多是事实，但它们确实会出现。
So I was working on a problem at work that was, it was really quite difficult. And we were having a discussion with my colleagues. And, uh, what is that? Why colleagues in quotation marks? I don't know.
所以我当时在工作中处理一个问题，它真的相当困难。我和同事们进行了讨论，呃，那是什么？为什么同事要加引号？我不知道。
Just because like, it sounds like really sophisticated, but they're, I don't know, they sound cool. My comrades. Yeah. So my, the people at work, you know, we were discussing this problem and we had had something that was really not doing well. The code was really slow.
只是因为听起来真的很高级，但他们，我不知道，他们听起来很酷。我的同志们。是的。所以我的同事们，你知道，我们正在讨论这个问题，我们之前处理得不太好。代码运行得很慢。
Everybody's like, hey, we should do better. So I came up with some way of kind of organizing the stuff to be better. And the question came up, which was sort of like, okay, well, how do we test this code? And how do we know if, can we do even better? How do we know if it's sort of doing what it's supposed to do, which was helping us out with some stuff? And it really kind of bothered me and i tried to convince some other people like you know i don't i don't really know what sort of the lower bound is on like how fast this code can run so i don't know whether or not to keep spending time on it and
每个人都说，嘿，我们应该做得更好。所以我想到了一种组织这些东西以使其更好的方法。然后问题就来了，就像是，好吧，我们该如何测试这段代码？我们怎么知道是否能做得更好？我们怎么知道它是否在做它应该做的事情，也就是帮助我们处理一些东西？这真的让我很困扰，我试图说服其他人，比如，我真的不知道这段代码运行速度的下限是多少，所以我不知道是否应该继续花时间在它上面，而且
kind of bring this full circle what ended up happening is one night or whatever it just sort of like got in my head what have you called like a bee in your bonnet it no that's not the right thing anyways just like i think it just sort of like nagged at my head and i couldn't stop thinking about like the whole drive home i normally listen to my audio book and actually just paused it and like drove in silence just like thinking in my head oh i've done that too yeah i've definitely had nights like that okay so like really bothered to like, just like distracted at dinner with my family, the whole nine yards. This happens to me every so often.
为了把话题绕回来，最后发生的事情是，有一天晚上，或者不管什么时候，它就突然出现在我的脑海里，你管这叫什么，心头大患？不，那不对。总之，就像是它一直在困扰我，我无法停止思考，回家的路上我通常听有声读物，但我实际上把它暂停了，就那样沉默地开车，脑子里一直在想。哦，我也做过那样的事。是的，我绝对有过那样的夜晚。好吧，所以真的很困扰，就像在和家人吃晚饭时心不在焉，方方面面都是。这种情况我偶尔会发生。
And, and finally, yeah, this happened. And this happens to me too. Not to joke. This happens to me too. And my wife will be,
最后，是的，这发生了。这种情况我也遇到过。不是开玩笑。这种情况我也遇到过。我妻子会说，
she'll say something like, are you even listening to me? And, and I think to myself, no, that's a really weird way to start a conversation so okay I don't know people call this like image I'm not gonna get off in this so so this really bothered me and I finally realized and that what I needed was you know what to
她会说些什么，比如你到底有没有在听我说话？我心想，不，这作为谈话的开头也太奇怪了。所以好吧，我不知道人们管这叫什么，我不会偏离主题了。所以这真的困扰着我，我终于意识到我需要的是，你知道，
search for like a tool or a method, and there was nothing. It's not like, okay, what problem is this? And you sort of rearranged it in my head a couple ways and realized, oh, what I have could be mapped like almost exactly onto the traveling salesman problem. So, or sort of one of the variants of the traveling salesman problem. Yeah, that's actually a really good point is, you know, there's a lot of things like sorting, for example, where it's kind of obvious when you need to sort. But there's this whole class of problems where, you know, they get applied in ways you wouldn't really expect. And, you know, like like Sudoku is literally graph coloring. And there's that's, you know, that's kind of a contrived example. But yeah, there's tons of real life phenomena that can be explained with canonical algorithms that you learn in university.
搜索某种工具或方法，但什么都没有。并不是说，好吧，这是什么问题？我在脑子里把问题重新排列了几次，意识到，哦，我所拥有的东西几乎可以完全映射到旅行商问题上。或者说是旅行商问题的变体之一。是的，这确实是一个很好的观点，你知道，有很多像排序这样的事情，当你需要排序时是很明显的。但有一整类问题，它们以你意想不到的方式被应用。比如数独实际上就是图着色问题。这是一个比较牵强的例子。但确实，有无数现实生活中的现象可以用你在大学里学到的经典算法来解释。
Well, I mean, maybe and maybe not. So like Sudoku, as your example, since I'm being a little bit vague here just because it's not really pertinent. But yeah, Sudoku is a good example so if you sat down and tried to like write a computer program to solve sudoku as a human would i don't think at least in my understanding of the graph coloring problem that would lend itself to oh yeah that's the graph coloring problem so you might go really far with various techniques um but but you know end up in sort of almost a local minima where you're just sort of like running out of ideas but realizing oh this is the graph coloring problem or learning what the graph coloring problem is would open you up to a whole new suite of approaches that that are sort of like
嗯，也许是，也许不是。所以就像你举的数独例子，因为我在这里说得有点模糊，因为它并不真正相关。但是的，数独是一个很好的例子。如果你坐下来尝试像人类一样编写一个计算机程序来解决数独，我不认为，至少根据我对图着色问题的理解，它会自然而然地让你想到“哦，那是图着色问题”。所以你可能会用各种技术走得很远，但最终陷入某种局部最优解，你只是想法用尽了，但意识到“哦，这是图着色问题”，或者学习什么是图着色问题，会为你打开一整套全新的方法，这些方法是
well established that everyone's like oh you just use that technique or this technique exactly like you would convert you know your problem into the traveling salesman problem or the graph coloring problem. And then there would be some solver on the Internet that's just like blazingly fast. Well, OK, so I didn't find that. That would be awesome. But but what I did realize is, OK, this is a traveling salesman problem. Oh, and to cover just in case you don't know that the traveling salesman problem, which I'll hand wave a little bit. But if you think about all the capitals of countries in the world, as an example, and you think about their points in 2D on a map,
公认的，每个人都会说，哦，你只要用那种技术或这种技术。就像你把你的问题转换成旅行商问题或图着色问题一样。然后互联网上会有一些求解器，速度快得惊人。好吧，我没找到那个。那会很棒。但我确实意识到，好的，这是一个旅行商问题。哦，为了以防你不知道旅行商问题，我会稍微解释一下。但如果你想想世界上所有的国家首都，作为一个例子，把它们看作地图上的二维点，
and there's various different statements of the problem, but for this one, imagine that there is a path from every city, every capital city to every other capital city. And what you wanna do is start in one of the cities and visit every one of the other cities one time before coming back to the city you started at and what you want is the path that visits all of the city traverses all of these edges between cities um in the shortest distance possible or the shortest time possible. And solving this is known to be what is called NP complete.
这个问题有各种不同的表述，但对于这个，想象一下从每个城市，每个首都城市到其他每个首都城市都有一条路径。你想做的是从其中一个城市出发，在回到出发城市之前，访问其他每一个城市一次。你想要的是以最短距离或最短时间访问所有城市、遍历所有城市间路径的路径。解决这个问题被称为 NP 完全问题。
Very, very hard. There's no like sort of polynomial time solution to this problem that is currently known. And so that just to get just to illustrate this. Right. So you're right. Let's say you're in New York and there's Boston pretty close by. Right. So you might say, oh,
非常非常难。目前还没有已知的多项式时间解法。所以为了说明这一点。对吧。所以你是对的。假设你在纽约，波士顿离得很近。对吧。所以你可能会说，哦，
I should go to Boston because it's right there, right? But if you have to go around the whole world, then maybe the best thing to do is to make Boston the last city you visit, right? A second to last city you visit, and then just go to New York at the end. But if you go to Boston first, then, you know, you've already drawn that line you don't need to draw it twice right so you have this conundrum of like should i go to boston right now or should i pick it up at the end on my way back and the only way you can answer that is to you know go to the end of the path and find out if you should go to boston or not but to do that you have to go to the end so So it's sort of like this paradox.
我应该去波士顿，因为它就在那儿，对吧？但如果你必须环游世界，那么最好的办法可能是把波士顿作为你访问的最后一个城市，对吧？倒数第二个访问的城市，然后最后去纽约。但如果你先去波士顿，那么，你知道，你已经画了那条线，你不需要画两次，对吧？所以你面临一个难题，比如我现在应该去波士顿吗？还是应该在回来的路上最后再去？唯一能回答这个问题的方法是，你知道，走到路径的尽头，看看你是否应该去波士顿。但要做到这一点，你必须走到尽头。所以这就像是一个悖论。
And yeah, you end up having to explore every possible option. If you want the, you know, sort of, if you want to guarantee that you will find the optimal path. Right. But it turns out, you know, I didn't actually need the optimal answer. I just wanted to know sort of like how far away I was from it. And so what I found by mapping this onto the traveling salesman problem is that,
是的，你最终不得不探索每一个可能的选项。如果你想要，你知道，如果你想保证找到最优路径。对吧。但事实证明，我并不真的需要最优解。我只是想知道我离最优解有多远。所以我通过将其映射到旅行商问题上发现，
and actually mentioning this to Jason in the pre-show, he actually like, oh, so you just use simulated annealing. So for me, that was what it was, was like, initially when I was thinking about this, I was like, oh, maybe I could just sort of try all the combinations. And then I realized, oh wait, yeah, that's like ridiculously large there's no way um and then i was then you know like maybe i'll just try random and then i realized like oh wait this traveling salesman problem and sort of the same logic jason had oh yeah i should try simulated annealing which for sake of time maybe we'll cover meta heuristics and searching in another time but it's just a way of saying hey i have a very gigantic
实际上在预演时向 Jason 提到了这一点，他实际上说，哦，那你直接用模拟退火算法就行了。所以对我来说，就是这样。最初我在想这个问题时，我在想，哦，也许我可以尝试所有的组合。然后我意识到，哦等等，那太庞大了，根本不可能。然后我就想，也许我只是随机尝试。然后我意识到，哦等等，这是旅行商问题，逻辑和 Jason 的一样，哦是的，我应该尝试模拟退火。为了节省时间，也许我们下次再讨论元启发式算法和搜索，但这只是说，嘿，我有一个非常巨大的
search space and i'm gonna try what amounts to randomly searching it but i'm gonna guide the random searches in a way so that i'm more likely to go in things that give me better and spend more time looking at things that give me better answers uh yeah i mean that's a non-statistic jason could probably give us a better statistics answer but that's the layman's uh my layman's yeah i mean no i think you hit the nail on the head i mean just to like explain it through an example right so you start by just doing a random walk where you just start at a city and you just pick at a random city and go there and just keep doing that until you you've done all the cities and then go back to your start, right? And so now you have an answer. It's probably really bad.
搜索空间，我打算尝试进行随机搜索，但我会引导这些随机搜索，这样我更有可能去往能给我更好结果的方向，并花更多时间研究那些能给我更好答案的东西。是的，我的意思是，那不是统计学，Jason 可能能给我们一个更好的统计学答案，但这是外行，我的外行理解。是的，我觉得你一针见血。我的意思是，通过一个例子来解释，对吧？你从随机游走开始，从一个城市出发，随机选择一个城市，然后一直这样做，直到你访问了所有城市，然后回到起点，对吧？现在你得到了一个答案。它可能真的很糟糕。
And then what you do is you randomly pick a city and move it somewhere else in the queue. So if there's a city that you visited third, you just pluck, you pick it up, and then you put it somewhere else. Maybe now you're going to visit it ninth, right? And if that new path is shorter than the old path, then you put it somewhere else. Maybe now you're going to visit it ninth, right? And if that new path is shorter than the old path, then you take it. You say, oh, I did something random and it's good. Take it. And if it's worse than what you had before, then sometimes you take it, sometimes you don't. And it's that sometimes that kind of lets you kind of do some exploration. And then you just keep doing that until you get an answer. And over time, you get less and less likely to take things that are worse until eventually you're just only taking better decisions.
然后你随机选择一个城市，把它移动到队列中的其他地方。如果有一个城市你是第三个访问的，你把它拿起来，放到其他地方。也许现在你要第九个去访问它，对吧？如果那条新路径比旧路径短，你就接受它。你说，哦，我做了一些随机的事情，结果很好。接受它。如果它比你之前的更差，那么有时你接受它，有时不接受。正是这种“有时”让你能够进行一些探索。然后你一直这样做，直到得到一个答案。随着时间的推移，你接受更差结果的可能性越来越小，直到最后你只接受更好的决策。
And so by doing this, I was able to find out that, oh, actually, the thing I came up with was pretty good. And I had somewhat confidence in that I had applied an appropriate technique. And so that was all of a sort of just an interesting thing that came up this week, but also this description of the importance of, you know, I probably haven't read about simulated annealing in five years, maybe since the last time we talked about maybe we talked about in the show since then. But I've never actually implemented it myself. I've never used it. It's not something that's at hand for the kind of work I normally do. But, you know, through this podcast, through, you know, just reading about computer science stuff, through having gone through school, it was something that allowed to pull out that tool, the toolbox, and allowed me to map a problem I had on to
通过这样做，我能够发现，哦，实际上，我想出的方法相当不错。我对自己应用了适当的技术有了一定的信心。所以这只是本周出现的一件有趣的事情，但也描述了重要性，你知道，我可能五年没读过关于模拟退火的内容了，也许自从我们上次在节目中讨论过之后。但我从来没有亲自实现过它。我从来没用过它。它不是我平时工作中手头会用的东西。但是，通过这个播客，通过阅读计算机科学的东西，通过上过学，它让我能够从工具箱里拿出那个工具，让我能够把我遇到的问题映射到
sort of well studied something. And, and a couple Google searches later, you know, led me to the, you know, pseudo code that I, you know, wrote up in, you know, a couple hours into, you know, a couple hundred lines of code and had my, it took a kind of a long time to run, actually, I just let it run overnight, but had the thing running overnight and cranking away at trying to improve my answer. Very cool. Yeah, the next step now would be to try to export your problem to TSP
某种研究透彻的东西上。几次谷歌搜索后，就找到了伪代码，我花了几小时写了几百行代码，让它运行起来。它运行起来确实花了不少时间，我只是让它通宵运行，但它通宵运行并努力改进我的答案。非常酷。是的，下一步就是尝试把你的问题导出到 TSP，
and see if some GitHub project has some, I don't know, like Gaussian process or something that's going to like really blow. Yeah, I saw there were some some like toolbox out there that are specifically for solving this. But my data set was actually bigger than most of them sort of had listed. So I'm sure they might work. But I wanted to find one that was like, yeah, I give it however much data you want. Because I had kind of a lot. You need to find one that's written in Julia.
看看有没有什么 GitHub 项目有高斯过程之类的东西，能真正大放异彩。是的，我看到有一些专门用于解决这个问题的工具箱。但我的数据集实际上比它们列出的大多数都要大。所以我肯定它们可能有用。但我想要找一个，比如，是的，我给它多少数据都行。因为我的数据量有点大。你需要找一个用 Julia 编写的。
That's next time, when I come back to spending some time on this problem. Very cool, man. So I have the first news, and this is Microsoft releases their training for artificial intelligence. We've seen kind of a lot of recent releases of videos and materials for training about machine learning and artificial intelligence.
那是下次的事了，等我回来花时间处理这个问题的时候。非常酷，伙计。我有第一条新闻，这是微软发布了他们的人工智能培训课程。我们最近看到了很多关于机器学习和人工智能培训的视频和材料发布。
These ones look pretty well produced. I haven't, to be full disclosure, I haven't actually watched any of them yet, but they seem well done and they're free. I like free. And Microsoft stated that they did this because they feel there's a gap in being able to hire people for doing machine learning roles.
这些看起来制作得相当不错。我还没看，坦白说，我还没看任何一个，但它们看起来做得很好，而且是免费的。我喜欢免费。微软表示他们这样做是因为他们觉得在招聘机器学习岗位的人才方面存在缺口。
Probably also as an advertisement, although I don't know. They are, I think, in their cloud platform rolling out some stuff for supporting people doing machine learning tasks. So I'm sure it's like a multi-faceted reason that they're they're releasing this but if you're interested and you haven't found something that really clicked with you yet check it out and see if uh if you can learn machine learning if you can learn to okay yeah i i haven't seen the videos either but uh uh you know i'm subscribed to like a bunch of ai like newsletters
可能也是一种广告，虽然我不知道。我想他们在他们的云平台上推出了一些支持人们进行机器学习任务的东西。所以我肯定这是一个多方面的原因，他们才发布这个。但如果你感兴趣，而且还没找到真正让你感兴趣的东西，去看看，看看你是否能学习机器学习。好吧，是的，我也没看过这些视频，但是，你知道，我订阅了一堆人工智能通讯，
and stuff and this is very very popular and so usually things that are popular just tend to be good that's kind of how it works the cream rises to the top or whatever so uh yeah i mean i i i haven't seen the videos but uh they come highly recommended um yeah my news is pretty interesting there's a you know a lot of these video games some of them cost money some of them are free but but they all have loot boxes and so for people who don't know a loot box is uh you have this box where you open it up and you get something random and it's usually something that doesn't affect the gameplay it's just cosmetic so for example um you could get you know a suit of armor for your character or a different suit of armor let's say so instead of your character looking black they look purple um you could get you a
之类的东西，这个非常非常受欢迎。通常受欢迎的东西往往都不错，这就是它的运作方式，优胜劣汰之类的。所以，是的，我没看过视频，但它们被强烈推荐。嗯，我的新闻很有趣，你知道有很多电子游戏，有些要钱，有些免费，但它们都有战利品箱。所以对于不知道的人来说，战利品箱就是，你有一个盒子，打开它，你会得到一些随机的东西，通常是不会影响游戏玩法的东西，只是装饰性的。例如，你可以得到你角色的盔甲，或者不同的盔甲，比如说，你的角色看起来不是黑色的，而是紫色的。你可以得到一个
new helmet or something but generally the these items they're just cosmetic and that way you don't really have regret like if you open the loot box and box and it's a scarf and you wanted a hat, it sucks, it's a bummer, but it doesn't affect your game at all. But the thing about it is, people, like anything, they associate social value to it, and so there's value to some of these items. Some of the items are very rare. So I think on Counter-Strike, there's a knife that's like a golden knife. It's just extremely rare.
新头盔之类的，但通常这些物品只是装饰性的，这样你就不会有遗憾。比如如果你打开战利品箱，里面是一条围巾，而你想要一顶帽子，这很糟糕，很扫兴，但它根本不影响你的游戏。但关键在于，人们像对待任何东西一样，赋予了它社会价值，所以其中一些物品是有价值的。有些物品非常稀有。所以我认为在《反恐精英》里，有一把金色的刀。它极其稀有。
And it sells for hundreds of real dollars to get one of these knives. And so because there's an economy around it, it is kind of gambling. It's like, you know, you open this box. Oh, and the part I didn't mention, you get some of the boxes, you know, as part of playing the game, but you can't open them without a key and the key costs money.
它能卖到数百美元。因为围绕它有一个经济体系，所以它有点像赌博。就像，你知道，你打开这个盒子。哦，我没提到的一点是，你玩游戏时会得到一些盒子，但没有钥匙你打不开它们，而钥匙要钱。
So, you know, the way it works is you both have to play the game a lot and you have to spend real money. So even if you had infinite money, you're limited in how much content you can get because you have to spend real money so so even if you had infinite money you're limited on in how much content you can get because you have to play and even if you play all day you're limited by money so on so forth um but you know you pay two dollars you unlock this box and maybe it has the 500 knife um or maybe it has you know i don't know the scarf that's worthless um and, you know, I don't know, the scarf that's worthless. And so, you know, especially in Europe, they're starting to kind of equate this with gambling. And I don't know.
所以，你知道，它的运作方式是你既要玩很多游戏，又要花真钱。所以即使你有无限的钱，你获得内容的能力也有限，因为你必须花真钱。所以即使你有无限的钱，你获得内容的能力也有限，因为你必须玩游戏，即使你整天玩，你也会受到金钱的限制，等等。但你知道，你付两美元，解锁这个盒子，也许里面有那把 500 美元的刀，或者也许里面有，我不知道，那条一文不值的围巾。而且，你知道，特别是在欧洲，他们开始把这等同于赌博。我不知道。
I don't really I haven't really formulated a strong opinion here, but I do think it's super interesting. I can definitely see the gambling argument. So, yeah, I'd be interested to see what hear what your take is Patrick but but yeah the article basically goes on to explain that in Belgium they've banned loot boxes so they've officially called them gambling and so all these games if they are operating in Belgium they need
我还没有形成强烈的观点，但我确实觉得这超级有趣。我绝对能看出赌博的论点。所以，是的，我很想听听你的看法，Patrick。但文章基本上解释了在比利时，他们已经禁止了战利品箱，所以他们正式称其为赌博，因此所有这些游戏如果要在比利时运营，就需要
to turn that that feature off this is tough I mean to be fair I don't think I've ever spent money on a free to play game like this i think i've spent money to like buy levels or something but i've never spent money for like a random chance at something or other uh including like i've i played hearthstone a little while you know the card game and i never paid to like open packets of games and i don't it that's that seems a little easier for me to reason about because in hearthstone it's sort of like opening magic the gathering cards right like i go to a store and i pay three dollars to get magic the gathering cards some of which are rare
关闭该功能。这很难，说实话，我不认为我曾经在这样的免费游戏中花过钱。我想我花钱买过关卡之类的，但我从来没为随机机会花过钱，包括我玩过一会儿《炉石传说》，你知道那个卡牌游戏，我从来没付钱去开卡包。这对我来说似乎更容易理解，因为在《炉石传说》里，它有点像开《万智牌》卡包，对吧？我去商店付三美元买《万智牌》卡牌，其中一些是稀有的，
and some of which are not i mean i don't but in theory i could um and i don't think you can sell the cards in hearthstone unless maybe not but but but the way it works like magic is going to a physical store and buying magic the gathering cards gambling uh i think it is wait uh i'd have to double check okay i don't actually hang on okay i would assume it's not considered gambling because i know people normally gambling is restricted or at least how i think about gambling in the legal sense is normally restricted to having to be 18 and i don't think you have to be 18 years old to to buy magic the gathering cards um oh that's true but but of course gambling could could mean lots of things um and so to me
一些不是。我的意思是，我不会，但理论上我可以。我不认为你能在《炉石传说》里卖卡牌，除非可能不行。但它的运作方式就像《万智牌》一样，去实体店买《万智牌》卡牌算赌博吗？我觉得是。等等，我得核实一下。好吧，我其实，等等。好吧，我会假设它不被视为赌博，因为我知道人们通常认为赌博是受限制的，或者至少我从法律意义上对赌博的理解通常限制在必须年满 18 岁。我不认为买《万智牌》卡牌必须年满 18 岁。哦，那是真的，但当然赌博可以意味着很多事情。所以对我来说，
like hearthstone like you said maybe the difference there is is gambling that i can sell it back or that i can get cash from it because in hearthstone i'm able to play the game better in theory i could play the game better and enter a tournament and then make money um because i have better cards and you need the better cards to be able to enter the tournaments or else you're just gonna to get, you know, crushed. And so in the, and I know in, in the one that's always brought up in Japan, is it called Pachinko? I think there's some sort of machine that they play with ball bearings and you
像《炉石传说》，就像你说的，也许那里的区别在于赌博是我可以把它卖掉，或者我可以从中得到现金。因为在《炉石传说》里，我能够更好地玩游戏，理论上我可以玩得更好，参加锦标赛，然后赚钱。因为我有更好的卡牌，你需要更好的卡牌才能参加锦标赛，否则你只会被碾压。我知道在日本总是被提到的那个，叫弹珠机（Pachinko）吗？我想有一种机器，他们用钢珠玩，你
buy money and you sort of put the ball. Oh, I've heard about that. And it's, it is, it is really gambling except that you only get, you know, these ball bearings,
买钱，然后你把球放进去。哦，我听说过那个。而且，它确实是赌博，除了你只得到这些钢珠，
which aren't really worth anything, except then you can go down the street and trade the ball bearings in for you know like uh something that has hard cash equivalents like a little gold coin like made of actual gold that has value for the gold in it um and so it's like one step removed but okay i mean if you go to a casino and they give you token, you know, what do they call poker chips? Those are technically not money, but you trade them for money. So I have the official rule on Magic the Gathering. I don't I'm not saying this is right, but I'm saying this is what is. Apparently, because you're getting something physical, it's OK.
它们其实不值什么钱，但你可以走到街上，把钢珠换成，你知道，像是有硬通货等价物的东西，比如一个小金币，由真正的黄金制成，具有黄金价值。所以它离赌博只有一步之遥。但好吧，我的意思是，如果你去赌场，他们给你代币，你知道，他们管那叫什么？筹码？那些在技术上不是钱，但你可以把它们换成钱。所以我有了关于《万智牌》的官方规则。我不是说这是对的，但我说这就是现状。显然，因为你得到的是实物，所以没问题。
And so I think the idea there is you know let's say you buy a car and i buy a car and your car ends up being a classic like let's say let's say like you buy the first model tesla and i buy just a honda civic and your tesla ends up being worth a lot of money just because it was the first one and my honda civic doesn't right like it doesn't that's not gambling and so uh i think the claim is you know you're buying these magic the gathering cards and you're you're paying for the cost of the card yeah and even though you don't really know what you're getting they also don't know what you're getting because they don't know in advance that something's going to be valuable even though they kind of do yeah that seems yeah that seems right it seems like convenient but because and if you say that i mean in reality what's the
所以我认为那里的想法是，你知道，假设你买了一辆车，我也买了一辆车，你的车最终成了经典款。假设你买了第一款特斯拉，我只买了本田思域，你的特斯拉最终因为它是第一款而变得很值钱，而我的本田思域没有。那不是赌博。所以我认为他们的主张是，你知道，你买这些《万智牌》卡牌，你支付的是卡牌的成本。是的，即使你不知道你会得到什么，他们也不知道你会得到什么，因为他们事先不知道某样东西会变得有价值，尽管他们多少知道一点。是的，这看起来，是的，这看起来是对的。这看起来很方便，但因为，如果你这么说，我的意思是，现实中，
difference between the digital games then because sure the company can artificially just make more or less but magic the gathering could just make more or less of any card past present or future they could just reprint a card. Yeah, I agree. Right? Yeah, yeah. I don't think it's a sensible argument, but that is the logic. Yeah.
数字游戏和它有什么区别呢？因为当然，公司可以人为地制造更多或更少，但《万智牌》也可以制造更多或更少任何过去、现在或未来的卡牌。他们可以重印一张卡。是的，我同意。对吧？是的，是的。我不认为这是一个合理的论点，但这就是逻辑。是的。
So, I mean, I do understand that it does seem an awful lot like gambling, right? Like, oh, I put money in, and sometimes I get big stuff out, and sometimes I get something that's not worth the money I put in. But the not worth the money I put in is applicable for lots of things. Like if you bought Magic the Gathering cards and were guaranteed to be able to sell every card, if the total value of the cards you had were always sellable for less than the packet price, you would buy infinitely many, right?
所以，我的意思是，我确实理解它看起来非常像赌博，对吧？就像，哦，我投入了钱，有时我得到大奖，有时我得到的东西不值我投入的钱。但“不值我投入的钱”适用于很多事情。比如如果你买了《万智牌》卡牌，并且保证能卖掉每一张卡，如果你的卡牌总价值总是能以低于卡包价格的价格卖出，你会买无数次，对吧？
Your expected value is higher. So we know that's not true. We know the expected value of an open packet of magic the gathering cards is different than the expected value before you open it right and it's going to be less on that yes or else you would buy infinitely many right you would always take that gamble okay um yes it's it's it's interesting i mean that's that's the rules i mean we'll see i mean i'm sure the video game companies are going to lobby as hard as they can. You know, and they probably have a case.
你的期望值更高。所以我们知道那不是真的。我们知道打开一包《万智牌》卡牌的期望值与打开它之前的期望值是不同的，而且会更低。是的，否则你会买无数次，对吧？你总是会进行那场赌博。好的，嗯，是的，这很有趣。我的意思是，这就是规则。我的意思是，我们会看到的。我的意思是，我肯定电子游戏公司会尽可能地游说。你知道，他们可能确实有理由。
My thing is, I think, you know, any type of, you know, any type of thing where you buy and there's an element of chance like this should probably be age restricted um i have a feeling like you know if you're 12 you probably can't really you know grasp this this like you know concept you know like you probably waste a lot of money like i know i waste a lot of money at the arcades and you know not a lot of money but like you know these people might be spending hundreds of dollars and see i feel like you probably should be a certain age or have parent consent well i will say for certain regardless of my feelings or the ethics or morality of it is that it's going to have a huge impact on the profitability of games if this becomes widespread yeah that's true although to be fair uh um well first of all you're totally right. But second, I think these kind of games rely on these people called whales who are just like a few people who spend an incredible amount of money.
我的观点是，我认为，你知道，任何类型的，你知道，任何你购买且带有这种机会成分的东西都应该进行年龄限制。我有一种感觉，比如，你知道，如果你 12 岁，你可能真的无法理解这个概念。你知道，你可能会浪费很多钱。我知道我在游乐厅浪费了很多钱，你知道，不是很多钱，但你知道，这些人可能会花数百美元。所以我觉得你可能应该达到一定年龄或者有父母同意。好吧，我会说，无论我的感受或其伦理道德如何，如果这种情况变得普遍，它肯定会对游戏的盈利能力产生巨大影响。是的，那是真的，尽管说实话，嗯，首先，你是完全正确的。但其次，我认为这类游戏依赖于所谓的“鲸鱼玩家”，他们只是少数花巨额资金的人。
So if they could get it age-restricted, I think they would still get 99% of their money probably. But who knows? Yeah, so that's a pretty controversial article. We'll have to see what happens. I mean, it's just one country in the EU, so it could be the whole EU bans it. It could be that it gets overturned.
所以如果他们能进行年龄限制，我想他们仍然能得到 99% 的钱。但谁知道呢？是的，所以那是一篇非常有争议的文章。我们得看看会发生什么。我的意思是，这只是欧盟的一个国家，所以可能是整个欧盟都禁止它。也可能是它被推翻。
We'll find out. Next article is on the taxonomy of tech debt. And this was posted on the Riot games engineering blog uh who are famous for making league of legends right yeah and um talks about actually some of the work behind league of legends and you know everybody talks about technical debt and i i guess technical debt is one of those things that is unavoidable if you always work to have no technical debt, then you're probably not going fast enough. You're probably going too slow.
我们会知道的。下一篇文章是关于技术债务的分类。这是发布在 Riot Games 工程博客上的，他们以制作《英雄联盟》而闻名，对吧？是的，嗯，谈到了《英雄联盟》背后的一些工作。你知道，每个人都在谈论技术债务。我猜技术债务是不可避免的事情之一。如果你总是努力做到没有技术债务，那么你可能走得不够快。你可能走得太慢了。
But this is an interesting approach with some real world examples. And I won't go through all of it because you should just read the article. But he basically comes up with some measures that he thinks it's important to measure, like impact, the cost to fix, and then what he calls contagion, the likeliness that the problem will spread throughout the whole system.
但这是一个有趣的方法，有一些现实世界的例子。我不会全部讲完，因为你应该直接去读那篇文章。但他基本上提出了一些他认为重要的衡量指标，比如影响、修复成本，以及他所说的传染性，即问题扩散到整个系统的可能性。
Um, and you know, sort of cause disruption. And then also whether the debt is sort of like local to an area or global, um, whether it's like somebody came in and did something crazy, like just sort of like, what would you call those?
嗯，你知道，某种程度上造成破坏。还有债务是局部的还是全局的，嗯，是否有人进来做了一些疯狂的事情，比如，你会怎么称呼那些？
Like arch types, arch types, uh, like prototype archetypes. There we go. Thank you. thank you uh it's late my brain's not working well archetypes of you know here's the kind of things that would cause various styles and he kind of writes about it so i encourage you to read it and i thought it was pretty well put and it's always a struggle to talk about technical debt and instead of shipping a new feature you know taking time to fix something that is probably not broken but is either has a risk to make something broken or is causing
像原型，原型，嗯，就像原型。这就对了。谢谢。谢谢。嗯，很晚了，我的大脑不太好使。各种原型，你知道，这里有会导致各种风格的事情，他写了关于这些的内容。所以我鼓励你去读它。我觉得它写得很好。谈论技术债务总是一种挣扎，而不是发布新功能，你知道，花时间去修复一些可能没有坏，但要么有导致某些东西坏掉的风险，要么正在导致
problems to slow down or hurting you know the joy of working in the code whatever it might be it's always difficult second so having more thoughts on how to think about and describe that is always welcome yeah totally makes sense yeah the worst kind of technical debt that i've been experiencing a lot of lately is where things just fail silently you know and that's one thing over the years i've gotten more and more loud with failures like you know if there's an input and it should be between 1 and 10 and it comes in as 11, I just crashed the whole binary. And part of it is because, you know,
减慢速度或损害代码工作乐趣的问题，无论它是什么，总是很困难。所以，有更多关于如何思考和描述这些的想法总是受欢迎的。是的，完全有道理。是的，我最近经常经历的最糟糕的技术债务是事情悄无声息地失败。你知道，这是我多年来变得越来越大声疾呼失败的一件事。比如，如果有一个输入，它应该在 1 到 10 之间，但输入的是 11，我直接让整个二进制文件崩溃。部分原因是，你知道，
I'm not working on like a rocket ship or something where you can't do that. But, you know, we've been really burned lately where, for example, we had this issue where this library was reading rows of data and if the data didn't fit you know if the data had errors basically it just skipped the row but it didn't warn you or anything and so uh we found that only 10 percent of our data was being read which uh and of course it wasn't a random 10 percent so it
我不是在做火箭之类的东西，你不能那样做。但是，你知道，我们最近真的被坑惨了。例如，我们遇到了这个问题，这个库在读取数据行，如果数据不符合，你知道，如果数据有错误，基本上它只是跳过了这一行，但它没有警告你或任何东西。所以，嗯，我们发现只有 10% 的数据被读取了，这，而且当然它不是随机的 10%，所以它
totally skewed you know all of our results um, yeah, stuff like that is the worst. So, yeah, that's, that's, that's especially, but yeah, this is cool. It's especially bad. Yeah. If you're doing something where you're building statistics or measuring something, because you could easily be missing, like you said, 90% of your data and it wouldn't be immediately obvious you were. Yep.
完全扭曲了我们所有的结果。是的，类似的事情是最糟糕的。所以，是的，那是，那是，那是特别的，但这很酷。这特别糟糕。是的。如果你在做构建统计数据或测量某些东西的事情，因为你可能很容易像你说的，丢失了 90% 的数据，而且不会立即显现出来。是的。
Yeah. It went on for a long time. Oh man. be immediately obvious you were yep yeah it went on for a long time oh man my article is ubuntu 18.4 is available so this is a big deal so ubuntu has um what's called lts versions long-term support versions and these are basically versions that um you know have been vetted very carefully and also if you're a paid you know um like if you're a corporate uh i guess sponsor of ubuntu or if you if you pay into their customer support all that uh they will support the lts versions for you know years and years and years so if you're on you know 17.10 after maybe 12 months they're like done like done. Like if you need help, I mean, I'm sure you could pay somebody to help you,
是的。它持续了很长时间。天哪。立即显现出来。是的，它持续了很长时间。天哪。我的文章是 Ubuntu 18.04 可用了。所以这是一件大事。所以 Ubuntu 有所谓的 LTS 版本，长期支持版本。这些基本上是经过非常仔细审查的版本。而且如果你是一个付费的，你知道，嗯，比如如果你是一个企业，我猜是 Ubuntu 的赞助商，或者如果你为他们的客户支持付费，所有这些，他们会支持 LTS 版本，你知道，很多年。所以如果你在用，你知道，17.10，在大约 12 个月后，他们就像结束了，结束了。如果你需要帮助，我的意思是，我肯定你可以付钱请人帮你，
but, you know, it's going to be much harder. But if you're on 16.4, you can get help for a long time, even years from now, right? And so the LTS versions are pretty rare because of the amount of, you know, customer support and all that that goes with it. Also, you have a lot of libraries. So if you need proprietary libraries, such as the CUDA library from NVIDIA, NVIDIA is actually pretty good about having it for different versions, but a lot of people just support the LTS version.
但是，你知道，这会困难得多。但如果你在用 16.04，你可以获得很长时间的帮助，甚至几年后，对吧？所以 LTS 版本非常罕见，因为随之而来的客户支持量等等。此外，你有很多库。所以如果你需要专有库，比如 NVIDIA 的 CUDA 库，NVIDIA 在为不同版本提供支持方面实际上做得相当不错，但很多人只支持 LTS 版本。
So if you have some custom driver, you know, you're stuck on 16.04, right? And so 18.04 is the LTS version, which means a lot of people who've been waiting to update can update. And, you know, you go from, I think it's like GCC 5 to 7 or something like that. It's a huge update, right? It's out. It came out today. I haven't updated yet any of the machines in my house or anything, but I'm looking forward to it. I think it looks a lot nicer.
所以如果你有自定义驱动程序，你知道，你被困在 16.04 上，对吧？所以 18.04 是 LTS 版本，这意味着很多一直在等待更新的人可以更新了。而且，你知道，你从，我想是 GCC 5 升级到 7 之类的。这是一个巨大的更新，对吧？它出来了。它今天发布了。我还没更新我家里的任何机器，但我很期待。我觉得它看起来好多了。
A lot of the graphical issues have been fixed. I think they were using LightDM. They switched back to GNOME, so it's going to look pretty different. I'm not sure what the upgrade path is, but if the upgrade path switches it back to GNOME, it's going to look pretty different. But yeah, it's a pretty big announcement. I'm looking sure what the upgrade path is but if the upgrade path switches it back to GNOME it's going to look pretty different
很多图形问题都修复了。我想他们之前用的是 LightDM。他们换回了 GNOME，所以它看起来会很不一样。我不确定升级路径是什么，但如果升级路径把它换回了 GNOME，它看起来会很不一样。但是的，这是一个相当大的公告。我不确定升级路径是什么，但如果升级路径把它换回了 GNOME，它看起来会很不一样。
but yeah it's a pretty big announcement looking forward to getting everyone on there Do you run Ubuntu at home? Yeah so I have basically I have two media center PCs one per television and they both run Ubuntu and my desktop
但确实，这是一个相当大的公告，很期待让大家都能用上。你在家里用 Ubuntu 吗？是的，我基本上有两台媒体中心电脑，每台电视配一台，它们都运行 Ubuntu，还有我的台式机。
dual boots but uh yeah i typically just stay in windows for that but i do have a bunch of on the desktop what about you are you running a bunch of no i run windows i'm a horrible person yeah you run uh i'm just kidding temple i'm just, I run Windows. I mean, my wife uses the computer, and so it's good to have Windows on this, which she's used to. And then, you know, I do it for some gaming. Yeah. I think Ubuntu has probably come a lot further,
是双启动的，但呃，是的，我通常只在 Windows 下使用它，不过我的台式机上确实有很多东西。你呢？你运行 Ubuntu 吗？不，我用 Windows，我是个糟糕的人。是的，你运行呃，我开玩笑的，坦普尔，我只是，我用 Windows。我的意思是，我妻子也用这台电脑，所以装 Windows 对她来说比较好，她习惯用这个。而且，你知道，我也用它玩一些游戏。是的。我觉得 Ubuntu 可能已经进步了很多，
and last time I used it, it was way better than the time I had used it before. So I'm sure it works pretty well. I just find myself not using desktops and laptops as often anymore. So yeah, I just don't have them up very often. And so they're just on Windows because that's what they've always been on. So like, do you have PCs hooked up to your television? So I have like Chromecast hooked up to my TV. Oh, okay.
上次我用它的时候，比我之前用的时候好多了。所以我相信它运行得相当不错。只是我发现自己不再那么频繁地使用台式机和笔记本电脑了。所以是的，我只是不常开它们。所以它们就一直运行着 Windows，因为它们一直都是这样。那么，你的电视上连接了电脑吗？我的电视上连了 Chromecast。哦，好吧。
Got it. And then I have a... go ahead oh i was gonna say i i i like pre-date chromecast so i just have computers for each tv but like uh you know yeah when they break i'm absolutely going to chromecast but for now yeah chromecast like the fire tvs like i think these ones work pretty well having a media pc does allow you to do some stuff i just found the hassle of dealing with it wasn't worth the few extra features that i wasn't using very often yeah and then i have a nas that uh has the ability to do stuff like have a plex server on it and stuff um but it runs a custom os from i think it's synology or whatever yeah so it runs some version of linux under the hood i don't know which one um but you i've i've
明白了。然后我有一个……你继续。哦，我本来想说，我，我，我比 Chromecast 出现得早，所以我每台电视都有电脑，但是，呃，你知道，是的，当它们坏了的时候，我绝对会换成 Chromecast，但目前来说，是的，Chromecast 就像 Fire TV 一样，我觉得这些东西运行得挺好。拥有一台媒体电脑确实能让你做一些事情，我只是觉得处理它的麻烦不值得那些我并不经常使用的额外功能。是的，然后我有一个 NAS，它有能力做一些事情，比如在上面运行 Plex 服务器之类的，嗯，但它运行的是一个定制的操作系统，我想是群晖之类的，是的，所以它底层运行的是某个版本的 Linux，我不知道是哪一个，但是你，我，我
not like jailbroken it i'm sure i could just run whatever on it i just run whatever it came with because i just wanted to be stable and you know keep itself happy yep so yeah boring setup i'm sorry there's no reason to do something crazy i should do something cool i had i mean we talked about this before the show but i you know we we talked about our networking setup a few shows ago and i had this totally jacked up uh you know netgear router that i just hacked and had all these extra services on and it basically died so uh yeah and i pretty much voided the warranty by you know doing all this crazy stuff so uh i'm just running stock stuff as well uh time for book of the show show my book of the show is econa economics but with an x
没有像越狱那样折腾它，我相信我可以在上面运行任何东西，但我只是运行它自带的系统，因为我只想让它保持稳定，你知道，让它自己运行良好。是的，所以，无聊的设置，抱歉，没有理由去做一些疯狂的事情。我应该做点酷的事情。我的意思是，我们在节目之前谈过这个，但我，你知道，我们几期节目之前谈过我们的网络设置，我有一个完全搞砸了的，呃，你知道，Netgear 路由器，我只是破解了它，并在上面运行了所有这些额外的服务，结果它基本上报废了，所以，呃，是的，我基本上也只是在运行原厂设置。呃，节目推荐书的时间到了。我的节目推荐书是《Econa》，经济学，但是带个 X。
so i think my last book of the show is basic economics by thomas soul i'm actually still reading that it's a very long book it's like 30 chapters um and you know it's also pretty dense so i have to kind of keep going back and rereading um so i'm kind of you know charging my way through that but uh there's a person on my team who is an actual economist um and he recommended this book as as a as another kind of book for for getting into economics this one is actually a um a comic book style um so if you're into like graphic novels and things like that um you know you'll like this um i haven't read it yet, so I can't vouch for it directly, but I've been some people who know way more about economics than me said this is the
所以我认为我上一本节目推荐书是托马斯·索维尔的《经济学基础》，我其实还在读那本书，那是一本很长的书，大概有 30 章，而且，你知道，它也相当晦涩，所以我不得不反复回去重读，所以我算是，你知道，正在努力啃完它。但是，呃，我团队里有一个人是真正的经济学家，他推荐了这本书，作为另一本入门经济学的书。这一本其实是，呃，漫画书风格的，所以如果你喜欢图形小说之类的东西，嗯，你知道，你会喜欢它的。我还没读过，所以我不能直接担保，但我认识一些比我更懂经济学的人说这是
book to get people started, get lay people started. And I'll definitely be reading it once I finish the Thomas Sowell book. Very nice. Yeah, you've been really into economics recently. Yeah, I think it's, it's, it's really, you know, got ahold of me. I think it's fascinating. I'm not so interested in like the stock market or anything like that, you know? But yeah, the way the engine works is just, is super, super interesting. And I feel like computer scientists should really study economics like the the you know thinking of it as this like really complex adaptive system taking it from
让人们入门，让外行入门的书。我肯定会在读完托马斯·索维尔那本书后读它。非常好。是的，你最近真的很迷经济学。是的，我觉得它，它，它真的，你知道，吸引了我。我觉得它很迷人。我对股市之类的东西不太感兴趣，你知道吗？但是，是的，引擎运作的方式，就是，超级，超级有趣。而且我觉得计算机科学家真的应该学习经济学，就像，你知道，把它看作是一个非常复杂的自适应系统，从
that perspective i think it's really interesting so we've now recommended that everyone go study more cs that everyone go study ai and machine learning that they all go learn economics we're gonna create an army of superhumans. This is, yeah, we're going to just keep going. We're going to have tons of recommendations. Yeah, if you've done any of these things, let us know. If you do the Microsoft course, you know, we're on Facebook, we're on Twitter.
那个角度来看，我觉得它真的很有趣。所以我们现在已经建议每个人去学习更多的计算机科学，每个人去学习人工智能和机器学习，他们都去学习经济学，我们要创造一支超人军队。这是，是的，我们要继续下去。我们将会有大量的推荐。是的，如果你做过这些事情中的任何一件，请告诉我们。如果你参加了微软的课程，你知道，我们在 Facebook 上，我们在 Twitter 上。
Actually, I think, so, you know, Facebook definitely has the biggest audience. But I think if I had to pick one place for people to, you know, message us, I think Twitter is probably it. When he says us, he means him. No, no, no. I mean, yeah, the Twitter is the Twitter is technically mine, but I never tweet unless it's about the show. So. So, yeah, it's at neural nets for life.
其实，我想，所以，你知道，Facebook 绝对拥有最大的受众。但我认为如果我必须选择一个让人们，你知道，给我们发消息的地方，我想 Twitter 可能是首选。当他说“我们”时，他指的是他自己。不，不，不。我的意思是，是的，Twitter 是，Twitter 在技术上是我的，但我从不发推文，除非是关于节目的。所以。所以，是的，它是 @neuralnetsforlife。
You can look it up on our homepage. But if you tweet us and you add us, unless it's about the show. So yeah, it's at neural nets for life. You can look it up on our homepage. But if you tweet us and you add us, then it's public. You know, like if you comment on our Facebook, it's kind of hard to find that. But I've noticed when people tweet at us, they typically, you know, then other people respond to them and it actually starts kind of a nice thread versus when someone comments on our post on Google Plus or Facebook, it just kind of dies nice thread versus one when someone comments to our on our post on google
你可以在我们的主页上查到它。但如果你给我们发推文并 @ 我们，除非是关于节目的。所以是的，它是 @neuralnetsforlife。你可以在我们的主页上查到它。但如果你给我们发推文并 @ 我们，那么它是公开的。你知道，就像如果你在我们的 Facebook 上评论，很难找到那个。但我注意到当人们在 Twitter 上 @ 我们时，他们通常，你知道，然后其他人会回复他们，它实际上开启了一个不错的讨论串，而当有人在我们的 Google Plus 或 Facebook 帖子下评论时，它就直接死掉了。
plus or facebook it just kind of dies the comment dies i haven't been on google i should go in there yeah i mean yeah if you've done uh any of these things writer economics book or or taking the microsoft course or anything let us know man it'd be great to hear my book of the show is black prism by brent weeks this is the first book in uh i think it's supposed to end up being five books i think the fifth book isn't out yet i'm not exactly sure because i'm only on the first book um and i think one of the there's like a book in between one of the books i maybe a short story or something. But Black Prism is pretty good. I've not read anything by this author before, Brent Weeks. I'm actually not quite done with it. I'm like one chapter away from the end or something. So it's like, you know, everything's
Plus 或 Facebook，它就直接死掉了，评论就消失了。我还没上过 Google，我应该去看看。是的，我的意思是，是的，如果你做过，呃，这些事情中的任何一件，写经济学书，或者参加微软的课程，或者任何事情，请告诉我们，伙计，听到这些会很棒。我的节目推荐书是布伦特·威克斯的《黑棱镜》，这是，我想应该是五本书系列中的第一本，我想第五本书还没出，我不确定，因为我只读到第一本，而且我想其中，书与书之间有一本，可能是一个短篇故事之类的。但《黑棱镜》相当不错。我以前没读过这个作者布伦特·威克斯的任何作品。我其实还没读完。我离结尾大概还差一章左右。所以就像，你知道，一切都在
kind of wrapping up or at least no spoilers. You know, I don't know, maybe it will or won't. But like one or two chapters from the end and I'm really enjoying it. It's a fantasy book. Um, and they have magic, but the magic is sort of based on a light, hence the name prism. Um,
某种程度上正在收尾，或者至少没有剧透。你知道，我不知道，也许会，也许不会。但就像离结尾还有一两章，我真的很喜欢它。这是一本奇幻书。嗯，他们有魔法，但魔法是基于光的，因此得名“棱镜”。嗯，
and so people use light and it has, it's not, uh, you know, super scientific, you know, whatever, but it's a sort of an interesting read
所以人们使用光，它不是，呃，你知道，超级科学的，你知道，什么的，但它是一种有趣的读物，
and an interesting play where people are able to use certain wavelengths of light to do things and so you might be able to use red light to do magic using red light and I might be able to use green light to do magic with green light and it just talks about various
一个有趣的设定，人们能够利用特定波长的光来做事情，所以你可能能够利用红光来使用红光魔法，而我可能能够利用绿光来使用绿光魔法，它只是谈论了各种
things along those lines for the magic system and i find it pretty interesting and book's been a good read so far some intrigue building up you can definitely tell it's gonna be part of a series so and i think the author actually has several other series in various states as well but um this one is part of the light bringer um saga so i'm enjoying it i'm enjoying i'm pretty pretty far through it and i recently started uh picking up a little bit of of podcasts too but i i don't know as much as we make a podcast and you should keep listening to our podcast uh something about like listening to a book i just
关于魔法系统的东西，我觉得它很有趣，而且这本书到目前为止读起来很不错，有一些阴谋正在酝酿，你绝对可以看出它将成为一个系列的一部分，而且我想作者实际上还有其他几个处于不同状态的系列，但是，嗯，这一本是“光明使者”传奇的一部分，所以我很享受它，我很享受，我已经读了相当多了，而且我最近也开始，呃，稍微听一点播客了，但我，我不知道，既然我们制作播客，你应该继续听我们的播客，关于听书之类的东西，我只是
like i don't know i get really into it and it's like really long form i'm actually doing both i'm listening to uh there's this podcaster stefan molyneux and he he talks about um um he's just like a really really hardcore libertarian like way more libertarian than i've ever seen like he's like you know there shouldn't even be public schools and just like way out there and And I just find it fascinating. I mean, I can't say I really agree with everything. But but yeah, I've been following his podcast and a couple others. So, yeah, I mean, I enjoy audio books. I use Audible. I have for like a long time now. I have so many books because I have a pretty long commute. But if you're interested in trying
喜欢，我不知道，我真的很投入，而且它是非常长篇的，我其实两者都在做，我正在听，呃，有一个播客主叫斯特凡·莫利纽克斯，他谈论，嗯，嗯，他就是一个非常非常硬核的自由意志主义者，比我见过的任何人都更自由意志主义，就像他认为，你知道，甚至不应该有公立学校，就像非常激进，我只是觉得这很迷人。我的意思是，我不能说我真的同意他的一切。但是，是的，我一直在关注他的播客和其他几个。所以，是的，我的意思是，我喜欢有声读物。我使用 Audible。我已经用了很长时间了。我有很多书，因为我通勤时间很长。但如果你有兴趣尝试
out Audible and you want to help the show, you can go to audibletrial.com slash programming throwdown and they'll give you a one month trial, which is good for a free book. It's pretty much any book in their whole catalog, which they have just like tons of stuff. And so you could check out,
Audible，并且你想支持这个节目，你可以去 audibletrial.com/programmingthrowdown，他们会给你一个月的试用期，这可以换取一本免费的书。这几乎是他们整个目录中的任何一本书，他们有海量的东西。所以你可以去看看，
Jason said economics is a comic book, so I won't even bother looking and seeing if they have that. But you could check out the Black Prism or look back through our show notes and see many books we've recommended or whatever your favorite might be and enjoy that. So that's like one. Yeah, do want a book that we have on the show and you have, let's say, the Audible credits, if you click on the link and then you buy the book, even using your Audible credits, that still helps the show, by the way. Oh, I did not know that. So, yeah, all our Audible listeners can still sort of help the show and get the book they want.
杰森说经济学是一本漫画书，所以我甚至不会费心去看看他们是否有那本。但你可以去看看《黑棱镜》，或者回顾我们的节目笔记，看看我们推荐的许多书，或者任何你最喜欢的书，并享受它。所以这就是一个。是的，想要一本我们在节目中提到的书，而且你，比如说，有 Audible 积分，如果你点击链接然后购买这本书，即使是使用你的 Audible 积分，顺便说一下，这仍然对节目有帮助。哦，我不知道这一点。所以，是的，我们所有的 Audible 听众仍然可以以某种方式帮助节目并获得他们想要的书。
So it's kind of free for you. It's like no effort by clicking on our link and then choosing the Audible choice. Oh, I didn't know that. That's a good tip cool yeah um you could also if you are already an audible customer or want to help out the show another way you can subscribe on patreon just to give you an update on the patreon so patrick has made all of the christmas prizes i know we're woefully late um but you know i still have all the addresses also by the way if you we only have
所以这对你来说是免费的。点击我们的链接然后选择 Audible 选项，几乎不需要任何努力。哦，我不知道。那是个好建议，酷。是的，嗯，如果你已经是 Audible 用户，或者想以另一种方式帮助节目，你可以在 Patreon 上订阅，只是给你更新一下 Patreon 的情况，帕特里克已经制作了所有的圣诞奖品，我知道我们迟到了，非常抱歉，但是，你知道，我仍然有所有的地址，顺便说一下，如果你，我们只有
addresses for about half of the Patreon subscribers so if you you know don't have your address on Patreon you know at this point just email me so if you send me an email just give me your name and your address your
大约一半 Patreon 订阅者的地址，所以如果你，你知道，在 Patreon 上没有你的地址，你知道，现在就给我发电子邮件，所以如果你给我发一封电子邮件，只需提供你的姓名和地址，你的
social security number your credit card yeah email uh just give me your name and your address your social security number your credit yeah no just just give me your name and your address and i will you know connect the dots and i will make sure that you get um a christmas present um but yeah i mean at the moment we actually have extras because uh so many people didn't uh don't have their address. You should post something on the Patreon feed too. I did already. Yeah, yeah. But if you didn't see that, or maybe you don't want your address on Patreon,
社会安全号码，你的信用卡，是的，电子邮件，呃，只需提供你的姓名和地址，你的社会安全号码，你的信用卡，不，不，只需提供你的姓名和地址，我就会，你知道，把它们联系起来，我会确保你得到，嗯，一份圣诞礼物，但是，是的，我的意思是，目前我们实际上有多余的，因为，呃，很多人没有，呃，没有他们的地址。你也应该在 Patreon 动态上发点什么。我已经发了。是的，是的。但如果你没看到，或者也许你不想在 Patreon 上留下你的地址，
it's totally fine. You can just send me an email, and we'll make sure to add you to it. Yeah, and it's also fine if you are like, I don't want to give these guys my address, and I don't want a prize. That's fine too. Oh, yeah, of yeah of course you want to be anonymous and mysterious if you don't want this i'm looking at them right now a whole stack of they're pretty cool i'm excited actually my my
完全没问题。你可以直接给我发电子邮件，我们会确保把你加进去。是的，如果你觉得，我不想把我的地址给这些人，我也不想要奖品，那也没关系。哦，是的，当然，如果你想保持匿名和神秘，如果你不想要这个，那也没关系。我正看着它们，整整一堆，它们很酷，我其实很兴奋，我的，我的
my son loves it uh you know i gave him one wait i don't know that those are childproof last i think they have sharp corners don't they Actually I think he broke one Oh don't let him eat it I would feel terrible if your son No he's five years old he's not going to eat it Time for tool of the show Tool of the show is forceps To get things out of your child's mouth
儿子很喜欢它，呃，你知道，我给了他一个，等等，我不知道那些是否防儿童，我想它们有尖角，不是吗？其实我觉得他弄坏了一个。哦，别让他吃掉它，如果你的儿子，我会感觉很糟糕。不，他五岁了，他不会吃掉它的。节目工具时间到了。节目工具是镊子，用来把你孩子嘴里的东西取出来。
After they've eaten it My tool of the show is brutal doom brutal uh this is really really cool so here's how it works um first you have to buy doom step one um you can either get doom one or doom two actually sorry you have to buy doom two um then you get this brutal doom so what this does does, it's kind of built on top of layers and layers. So there's a lot going on here, but I'll try to break it down as simple as possible. Basically, so doom, the source code for doom was released by id Software a long time ago, maybe like 15 years ago or something, right?
在他们吃掉之后。我的节目工具是《Brutal Doom》，残酷毁灭战士，呃，这个真的真的非常酷，所以它是这样运作的，嗯，首先你必须购买《毁灭战士》，第一步，你可以买《毁灭战士 1》或《毁灭战士 2》，其实抱歉，你必须买《毁灭战士 2》，然后你得到这个《Brutal Doom》，所以它所做的是，它有点建立在层层之上。所以这里有很多东西，但我会尽量把它拆解得尽可能简单。基本上，所以《毁灭战士》，《毁灭战士》的源代码很久以前由 id Software 发布了，也许是 15 年前什么的，对吧？
And maybe not that long ago, but a long time ago. And someone, you know, just went through and, you know, took the parts of the source code that load all of the data, and they, you know, brought that over, but then they rewrote the whole game engine. And so you can use the mouse to look around. You know, it's just faster. There's no limit to the number of enemies that could be on the screen at one time.
也许没那么久，但很久以前。然后有人，你知道，只是通读了一遍，你知道，拿走了加载所有数据的源代码部分，然后他们，你知道，把它移植了过来，但随后他们重写了整个游戏引擎。所以你可以用鼠标环顾四周。你知道，它只是更快。屏幕上同时出现的敌人数量没有限制。
I mean, all these, you know, all limitations are gone. And it looks way better, et cetera, et cetera. So it plays just like a modern FPS now, right? And so then there's this thing called Brutal Doom, which is where somebody has modified the engine to just make the game basically more intense. And so the way it works is it it kind of sits on top of the existing game content and it kind of patches it and then also patches the engine. So, for example, there's all the weapons are different. The enemies are different like
我的意思是，所有这些，你知道，所有限制都消失了。而且它看起来好多了，等等，等等。所以它现在玩起来就像一个现代的第一人称射击游戏，对吧？然后就有了一个叫《Brutal Doom》的东西，这是有人修改了引擎，让游戏基本上更激烈。所以它的工作方式是，它有点坐在现有的游戏内容之上，它有点修补它，然后也修补了引擎。所以，例如，所有的武器都不同了。敌人也不同了，比如
their ai is totally different they look different they don't look different but they um uh uh they have different attacks for example like the imps will actually jump at you the demons like jump um these so they act different and they have different animations and stuff. And it's also just extremely brutal and very satisfying. It's kind of, I don't want to say it's like it messed, it is kind of messed up. It's kind of messed up. Like if you shoot one of the enemies, sometimes they like lose a limb and then they start like kind of like crying and you have to kind of put them out of misery it's like kind of weird yeah it's kind of messed up but it's super super intense um everything is really fast you're like it's way it's it's by far the fastest
他们的人工智能完全不同，他们看起来不同，他们看起来并不不同，但他们，呃，呃，他们有不同的攻击方式，例如，小鬼实际上会跳向你，恶魔会跳，这些，所以他们的行为不同，他们有不同的动画之类的。而且它也非常残酷，非常令人满足。它有点，我不想说它像搞砸了，它确实有点搞砸了。它有点搞砸了。就像如果你射击其中一个敌人，有时他们会像失去一个肢体，然后他们开始像哭泣，你必须像把他们从痛苦中解脱出来，这有点奇怪。是的，它有点搞砸了，但它超级超级激烈，嗯，一切都非常快，你就像，它是迄今为止最快的
fps i've ever played like you just move so. You move faster than the rockets and stuff, right? That's always kind of been true in Doom. But this really takes it to the next level. You know, you can play co-op. It supports, like, playing over the internet, so you don't have to play over, like, an IPX wire or anything anymore. And it is just super,
我玩过的第一人称射击游戏，就像你移动得如此之快。你移动得比火箭之类的东西还快，对吧？这在《毁灭战士》中一直都是真的。但这真的把它提升到了一个新的水平。你知道，你可以玩合作模式。它支持，比如，通过互联网玩，所以你不再需要通过，比如，IPX 线之类的东西玩了。而且它只是超级
super fun and satisfying. If you like Doom, you'll just absolutely love this. The other part of this is this guy actually went ahead and built his own campaign. So a whole new set of levels. And he calls it the Hell on Earth pack. And it's something like 30 or 40 levels. They're extremely, extremely well done. Super high quality, like some really interesting stuff.
超级有趣和令人满足。如果你喜欢《毁灭战士》，你绝对会喜欢这个。这个的另一部分是，这个家伙实际上继续构建了他自己的战役。所以一套全新的关卡。他称之为“人间地狱”包。它有 30 或 40 个关卡。它们做得非常非常出色。超级高质量，就像一些非常有趣的东西。
He kind of keeps you on the edge of your seat. He's got friendly AI. So there's a part where you fight like a huge battle. You and a bunch of AI Marines fighting a bunch of enemies. There's a part where you lay siege to a castle with catapults. Like it's insane um and uh to top it off he's actually releasing another whole new set of 30 levels like a completely new campaign um and they're going through the beta testing now you can get the campaign if you subscribe to him on patreon
他让你一直处于紧张状态。他有友好的 AI。所以有一个部分是你进行一场巨大的战斗。你和一群 AI 海军陆战队员与一群敌人战斗。有一个部分是你用弹射器围攻一座城堡。就像它很疯狂，嗯，而且，呃，最重要的是，他实际上正在发布另一套全新的 30 个关卡，就像一个全新的战役，而且他们现在正在进行 Beta 测试，如果你在 Patreon 上订阅他，你可以得到这个战役，
or you can just wait i think it's going to come out in a few months. Um, but I played this, I thought, Oh, the other, the last part of this is, you know, you don't have to play these new campaigns. You can actually play the original doom or doom too, just with, you know,
或者你可以等，我想几个月后它就会出来。嗯，但我玩了这个，我想，哦，这个的最后一部分是，你知道，你不必玩这些新战役。你实际上可以玩原始的《毁灭战士》或《毁灭战士 2》，只是用，你知道，
the modified, um, uh, you know, engine and, and it will, you know, the,
修改后的，嗯，呃，你知道，引擎，而且它会，你知道，
the, the designers have made sure that the games are beatable and, and all of that. Um, super, super fun super fun I highly highly recommend it it's brutal it's brutal well prepare to groan
设计师们已经确保游戏是可以通关的，等等。嗯，超级超级有趣，超级有趣，我强烈强烈推荐它，它很残酷，它很残酷。好吧，准备好呻吟吧。
my tool of the show is YouTube I was telling Jason before the show know i stand by this you know there's my life would be different in many ways if youtube didn't exist um yeah i mean joking aside youtube is probably the best tool we've had on the show i mean if we just look at it objectively yeah i mean i i think i take it for granted and we've been on seven years now so there there are probably people listening to the show now who are like, yeah, man, YouTube's like TV. Like you wouldn't be like TV is the best tool. But, you know, thinking about, oh, I'm going to go.
我的节目工具是 YouTube。我在节目开始前告诉杰森，我知道我坚持这一点，你知道，如果 YouTube 不存在，我的生活会在很多方面有所不同，嗯，是的，我的意思是，撇开玩笑不谈，YouTube 可能是我们在节目中拥有的最好的工具，我的意思是，如果我们客观地看它。是的，我的意思是，我想我把它视为理所当然，我们已经做了七年了，所以现在听节目的人可能觉得，是的，伙计，YouTube 就像电视。就像你不会说电视是最好的工具。但是，你知道，想到，哦，我要去。
I went skiing a couple months ago and I've I'd never taken lessons. My dad sort of taught me how to do it. I'm really horrible at it. And I was like, I kind of want to be better. lessons are expensive i'm gonna look on youtube sure enough when on youtube there's like you know super professional videos and instructions about how to ski and like do better at skiing and sure it's probably not anything close to paying good money for a real instructor but you know it definitely helped me and I know I skied better because of it. Um, and I didn't, it didn't cost me anything other than time that I probably
我几个月前去滑雪，我从来没上过课。我爸爸算是教了我怎么做。我在这方面真的很糟糕。我就想，我有点想变得更好。课程很贵，我要在 YouTube 上看看。果然，在 YouTube 上有，你知道，超级专业的视频和关于如何滑雪以及如何滑得更好的指导，当然，这可能和花好钱请真正的教练没什么可比性，但你知道，它确实帮助了我，我知道我因为这个滑得更好了。嗯，而且我没有，它没花我任何东西，除了我可能
would have spent doing something else anyways. Uh, and just the amount of learning you can do on YouTube and using it for like repairs around your house or, uh, fixing problems and things that just would never like reading someone talk about skiing just doesn't work i couldn't have found someone's blog and been like oh i see what i'm done wrong no you really video is the way right i mean it's just it's it's sort of obvious yeah yeah when i had to learn how to uh basically a part of my son's bed kind of broke and i wanted to fix it and also kind of just reinforce the bed. Cause it's cheap Ikea bed.
本来会花在做别的事情上的时间。呃，而且你在 YouTube 上可以学到的东西量，以及用它来做家里的维修，或者，呃，解决问题，以及那些永远不会像读别人谈论滑雪那样有效的事情，我找不到别人的博客然后说，哦，我看到我做错了什么，不，你真的，视频才是方式，对吧？我的意思是，它只是，它有点显而易见。是的，是的，当我不得不学习如何，呃，基本上我儿子的床坏了一部分，我想修理它，也想稍微加固一下床。因为它是便宜的宜家床。
And, uh, yeah, I went on YouTube and I looked up, you know, how do I use a jigsaw? How do I use a table saw? And,
而且，呃，是的，我上了 YouTube，我查了，你知道，我怎么用曲线锯？我怎么用台锯？而且，
uh, yeah, I mean, just seeing someone do it is so important because especially you can watch 10 people do it or a hundred people do it. And each time you'll learn something a little different. Yeah. And it is true that sometimes you can get bad advice uh but but i think you said earlier you know kind of cream
呃，是的，我的意思是，看到别人做这件事太重要了，因为特别是你可以看 10 个人做它，或者 100 个人做它。每次你都会学到一点不同的东西。是的。而且确实有时你会得到糟糕的建议，呃，但我认为你之前说过，你知道，某种程度上奶油
rises to the top i think often especially in the like how-to stuff like the people who kind of are doing stuff that's very dangerous often get flagged for doing stuff that's very dangerous so yeah i mean i looked up how to use a jigsaw, and the video had millions of views, and it was just very professionally curated. And yeah, I mean, in theory, yeah, and if someone could trick you, for one, they'd probably have a lot of thumbs downs.
会浮到上面，我认为通常特别是在像“如何做”的东西中，那些做非常危险的事情的人通常会因为做非常危险的事情而被标记，所以是的，我的意思是，我查了如何使用曲线锯，那个视频有数百万次观看，而且它非常专业地策划。而且是的，我的意思是，理论上，是的，如果有人能欺骗你，首先，他们可能会有很多踩。
That has a big impact on the search results and all that. So yeah, I wouldn't worry too much about it. But specifically the thing, and this relates to kind of what we were talking about uh you know things that you don't use often but when you do wow that's nice uh is i've been watching this channel three blue one brown and this guy goes into like all sorts of discussion about math and not like oh here what is the oh man con academy you know it's like very practical math and how to learn that's great too um but that's very different this is like for math that you would never or i
这对搜索结果和所有这些都有很大的影响。所以是的，我不会太担心它。但具体的事情，这与我们正在谈论的某种程度上有关，呃，你知道，你不经常使用但当你使用时哇那很不错的东西，是我一直在看这个频道 Three Blue One Brown，这个家伙深入探讨了各种关于数学的讨论，而不是像，哦，这里什么是，哦，伙计，可汗学院，你知道，这就像非常实用的数学以及如何学习，那也很棒，嗯，但这非常不同，这就像对于你永远不会，或者我
personally would never have attempted before like the riemann zeta function uh and he'll describe in like a it makes me feel like a superhero like i understand the riemann zeta function and what the zeros and how it relates to prime i mean i don't but i watched it he convinced me that like oh it's totally obvious and intuitive how these things relate to the primes and why and um just a great video great channel i don't remember how i came across it i think maybe i had number file on a while ago i think last time uh and this i think was sort of referred to it and i may have even talked about it last month if i did oh well
个人永远不会尝试的数学，比如黎曼 zeta 函数，他会用一种，它让我感觉像个超级英雄，我理解黎曼 zeta 函数以及零点是什么，以及它如何与素数相关，我的意思是，我不理解，但我看了它，他让我相信，哦，这些东西如何与素数相关以及为什么，这完全是显而易见和直观的，而且，嗯，只是一个很棒的视频，很棒的频道，我不记得我是怎么发现它的，我想也许我很久以前有 Numberphile，我想上次，呃，而且这个我想是某种程度上提到了它，我可能上个月甚至谈论过它，如果我谈过，哦，好吧
because it's really good the videos are a little long um but you know definitely worth it the explanations he gives and the understanding of math and i think it's one of those things where although i'll never probably have use for the riemann zeta function like the way he breaks down and thinks and he does this talking about mapping from one problem onto another for looking for solutions which is very common in mathematical proofs um and that technique right it just helps get you thinking about those kinds of things enormously valuable so youtube and for a specific channel recommendation because why not two for one three blue one brown very cool yeah i mean a similar one that i follow is called ted ed where it's um i don't know how it's affiliated with ted but it's just high quality
因为它真的很好，视频有点长，嗯，但你知道，绝对值得，他给出的解释和对数学的理解，而且我认为这是那种事情之一，虽然我可能永远不会用到黎曼 zeta 函数，但他分解和思考的方式，他这样做谈论将一个问题映射到另一个问题上以寻找解决方案，这在数学证明中非常常见，而且那种技术，它只是有助于让你思考那些事情，非常有价值，所以 YouTube，以及为了一个具体的频道推荐，因为为什么不二合一，Three Blue One Brown，非常酷。是的，我的意思是，我关注的一个类似的频道叫 TED-Ed，它是，嗯，我不知道它怎么与 TED 关联，但它只是高质量
uh no uh it's it's high quality like uh uh like cartoon style animations but explaining some concept like they had one uh the other day that was uh why you can't divide by zero and um but i mean the thing is i mean obviously you can't they go into like why you can't do that and why if you could then one would equal two or whatever but then they explain how you can't even really fudge around it like you can't say one over zero is infinity like you can't really even write a rule to to handle that because any rule you write ends up contradicting itself and it's just super interesting um very cool time for talking about julia julia my wife actually saw you know julia on my computer and she's like who's that i would name some famous actress but i'm drawing a blank julia there's some
呃，不，呃，它是高质量的，像，呃，呃，像卡通风格的动画，但解释一些概念，比如他们前几天有一个，是，呃，为什么你不能除以零，而且，嗯，但我的意思是，事情是，我的意思是，显然你不能，他们深入探讨了为什么你不能那样做，以及为什么如果你能那样做，那么 1 就等于 2 之类的，但随后他们解释了你甚至不能真正地绕过它，比如你不能说 1 除以 0 是无穷大，比如你甚至不能真正写出一个规则来处理它，因为你写的任何规则最终都会自相矛盾，而且它只是超级有趣，嗯，非常酷。谈论 Julia 的时间到了，Julia，我妻子其实看到，你知道，我电脑上的 Julia，她就像，那是谁？我会说出一些著名女演员的名字，但我脑子一片空白，Julia，有一些
julia julia roberts ah maybe i was thinking julia childs she's a chef right oh yeah right yes we know pop culture um yeah exact first cultural reference seven years in um so you know to talk about julia you really have to talk about scientific programming like at a high level because julia is in this class of languages you know that contains you know matlab and and R and things like that, NumPy. And the core idea behind all of these has been that you have a slow interpreter, like the MATLAB interpreter is just extremely slow, but then each individual instruction is super fast for what you're doing. So to illustrate an example, let's say you have two vectors, and they're of length a million each, and you want to add them together.
朱莉娅·罗伯茨，啊，也许我在想朱莉娅·蔡尔德，她是厨师，对吧？哦，是的，没错，是的，我们知道流行文化，嗯，是的，准确的第一个文化参考，七年了，所以，你知道，要谈论 Julia，你真的必须谈论科学编程，在高层面上，因为 Julia 属于这类语言，你知道，包含，你知道，MATLAB 和 R 之类的东西，NumPy。所有这些背后的核心思想一直是，你有一个缓慢的解释器，比如 MATLAB 解释器只是非常慢，但随后每个单独的指令对于你正在做的事情来说都是超级快的。为了说明一个例子，假设你有两个向量，它们每个长度为一百万，你想把它们加在一起。
Well, if you write a for loop in MATLAB, for 1 to a million, c of i is a of i plus b of i. That's going to take a long time. I mean, like, maybe a minute right but if you do c equals a plus b you know if it's just one line in the interpreter that line can be very complicated and time consuming and matlab will do that just extremely fast like a i don't know not even acond, like a fraction of a millisecond, right? And so the way that these things work is under the hood for each instruction, each instruction maps to a bunch of really complicated but extremely fast logic. So there's BLAS libraries, which we've talked about in the past. BLAS means basic linear algebra system.
好吧，如果你在 MATLAB 中写一个 for 循环，从 1 到一百万，c(i) = a(i) + b(i)。那将花费很长时间。我的意思是，比如，可能一分钟，对吧？但如果你做 c = a + b，你知道，如果它只是解释器中的一行，那一行可能非常复杂且耗时，而 MATLAB 会非常快地做到这一点，就像，我不知道，甚至不是一秒，就像一毫秒的一小部分，对吧？所以这些东西的工作方式是，在底层，对于每个指令，每个指令映射到一堆非常复杂但速度极快的逻辑。所以有 BLAS 库，我们过去谈论过。BLAS 意味着基本线性代数系统。
So, for example, you know, there's sort of an API that you can adhere to to be a BLAS library. And it says things like, you know, add two vectors, add two matrices, multiply matrices, so on and so forth. And if you implement all of these functions, then you support, you know, BLAS level one or whatever, right? And so, you know, the best, these BLAS libraries, you know, they have trade-offs, and MATLAB typically has all of them, and it knows to use
所以，例如，你知道，有一种 API 你可以遵守以成为 BLAS 库。它说的事情，比如，你知道，添加两个向量，添加两个矩阵，乘以矩阵，等等等等。如果你实现了所有这些函数，那么你就支持，你知道，BLAS 1 级之类的，对吧？所以，你知道，最好的，这些 BLAS 库，你知道，它们有权衡，而 MATLAB 通常拥有所有这些，并且它知道使用
the right one at the right time. There's things like FFTW, which stands for Fastest Fourier Transform in the West, which is just, as it says, just a super fast Fourier transform in the West which is just as it says just a super fast Fourier transform library things like OpenMP for multiprocessor support things like that
在正确的时间使用正确的那个。有像 FFTW 这样的东西，它代表“西方最快的傅里叶变换”，它只是，正如它所说，只是一个超级快的傅里叶变换库，像 OpenMP 这样的东西用于多处理器支持，诸如此类的东西，
and so you don't have to know how any of these things work or that even any of them are happening because it's all kind of behind the scenes but the price you pay there is that you know each instruction now requires you know a lot of thinking you know my life has to really think about um you know what to do and so things like for loops are just going to kind of kill your performance so um the last oh go ahead so the when you said that, you know, the realm of scientific programming or whatever, I mean, this is one of those places where
所以你不必知道这些东西是如何工作的，甚至不必知道它们中的任何一个正在发生，因为它们都在某种程度上在幕后，但你付出的代价是，你知道，每个指令现在都需要，你知道，大量的思考，你知道，我的生活必须真正思考，嗯，你知道，做什么，所以像 for 循环这样的东西只会某种程度上扼杀你的性能，所以，嗯，最后一个，哦，你继续，所以当你那样说时，你知道，科学编程领域之类的，我的意思是，这是那种地方之一，其中
that there's actually still a lot of people using Fortran, using, see, they, you know, sometimes I think like scientific programming, people using SciPy and NumPy. But I mean, there's still a lot of people using languages much older than that. Yeah, that makes sense i mean like i feel i you you're more in that realm i guess than i am so i mean is like of the mindshare is julia competing against these old ones or competing against something like python i think julia is really competing with matlab um so so at work um you know there there's some
实际上仍然有很多人在使用 Fortran，使用 C，他们，你知道，有时我想像科学编程，人们使用 SciPy 和 NumPy。但是，我的意思是，仍然有很多人在使用比那古老得多的语言。是的，这说得通，我的意思是，我觉得你，你在这个领域比我多，我想，所以，我的意思是，在思想份额方面，Julia 是在与这些古老的语言竞争，还是在与像 Python 这样的东西竞争？我认为 Julia 真的在与 MATLAB 竞争，所以，所以，在工作中，嗯，你知道，有一些
people using julia uh not really on my team but uh it's a huge company and there's a whole group of people um using julia and i noticed almost all of them are xr or x matlab people so yeah i think um you know so yeah to your point, I mean, when you say scientific programming, of course, like, you can do scientific programming in anything. But typically, like scientific programming languages are ones that are more high level, that make it easy to experiment. And so that's why most of these languages will have an IDE built in. So for example, MATLAB has MATLAB. You start MATLAB, and it pops up this whole developer environment where you can see the status of variables and look at plots
人在使用 Julia，呃，不是真的在我的团队里，但它是一家大公司，有一整群人，嗯，在使用 Julia，我注意到他们几乎所有人都是前 R 或前 MATLAB 的人，所以是的，我想，嗯，你知道，所以，是的，说到你的观点，我的意思是，当你谈论科学编程时，当然，比如，你可以在任何东西中进行科学编程。但通常，比如科学编程语言是那些更高级的，使实验变得容易的语言。所以这就是为什么大多数这些语言都会内置一个 IDE。所以例如，MATLAB 有 MATLAB。你启动 MATLAB，它会弹出整个开发环境，在那里你可以看到变量的状态并查看图表
and things like that while you're coding. And so for Julia or NumPy or any of these, you'd be using Jupyter, which Jupyter is the rebranding of IPython Notebook. And so one of the reasons for that rebranding is Jupyter supports Julia, supports Torch, which is in Lua, and a bunch of other things. Nice.
以及诸如此类的东西，当你正在编码时。所以对于 Julia 或 NumPy 或任何这些，你将使用 Jupyter，Jupyter 是 IPython Notebook 的重命名。所以重命名的原因之一是 Jupyter 支持 Julia，支持 Torch，它在 Lua 中，以及其他许多东西。不错。
Supports, what's it called? Spark. You can do Spark in Jupyter now. So what are the, so for Julia itself though, what are the features that it really has? Yeah, it's a good question. So like, why does Julia, you know, like really stand out, right? So if you, let's say you're a MATLAB user or an R user, what's really the reason to switch, right? about back in episode 41, which was probably years ago. But in the Node.js episode, we talked
支持，它叫什么？Spark。你现在可以在 Jupyter 中做 Spark。那么，对于 Julia 本身，它真正拥有的功能是什么？是的，这是个好问题。所以，比如，为什么 Julia，你知道，真的脱颖而出，对吧？所以如果你，假设你是一个 MATLAB 用户或 R 用户，切换的真正原因是什么，对吧？关于回到第 41 集，那可能是几年前了。但在 Node.js 那一集，我们谈论了
really about this whole async paradigm. And the idea with async is pretty simple. It's just, you know, you call a function, but instead of it doing what it's supposed to do, it just goes off and starts working and it gives you a future. So let's say you and Julia, and I'm going to kind of be a little hand-wavy here just so I don't have to, like, speak in code. But in Julia, you say async 1 plus 1. And it doesn't return that line. If you say a equals async 1 plus 1, that's not just going to, a is not going to be 2. a is going to be equal to a future.
真正关于这个整个异步范式。异步的想法很简单。它只是，你知道，你调用一个函数，但它不是做它应该做的事情，它只是走开并开始工作，它给你一个未来。所以假设你和 Julia，我将有点含糊其辞，这样我就不必，比如，用代码说话。但在 Julia 中，你说 async 1 + 1。它不会返回那一行。如果你说 a = async 1 + 1，那不会只是，a 不会是 2。a 将等于一个未来。
And then whenever you go to use a, so let's say you now say c equals a plus b. Now c is going to be a future. And this keeps going and going. And eventually you're going to need to know a value. So let's say you print c or write c to a file or something like that. Now all of a sudden Julia says, whoa, hang on. on all of these features I need to know now what they actually are and so what it's going to do is it's going to you know start waiting blocking on these features so it's gonna say hey see you know do you know what you are yet and see says no, no, I'm waiting on A. He says, oh, okay, A, have you figured it out yet? No, not yet? Okay, I'm just going to hang out.
然后每当你去使用 a 时，所以假设你现在说 c = a + b。现在 c 将是一个未来。这会一直持续下去。最终你需要知道一个值。所以假设你打印 c 或将 c 写入文件之类的。现在突然间 Julia 说，哇，等一下。在所有这些功能上，我现在需要知道它们实际上是什么，所以它要做的是，它要，你知道，开始等待，阻塞这些功能，所以它要说，嘿，c，你知道你是什么了吗？而 c 说，不，不，我在等 A。他说，哦，好吧，A，你弄清楚了吗？不，还没？好吧，我只是要等一下。
And then A says, oh, yeah, I figured it out. One plus one is two. And then C says, oh, now I got my value too. And then now you print C, right? And so, you know, when you're writing code like this, you're just accumulating a lot of these features. But then, you know, while this interpreter is running and doing this, you know, those features correspond to, you know, tasks that are running and they could be their co-routines. So they're running in the
然后 A 说，哦，是的，我弄清楚了。1 加 1 是 2。然后 C 说，哦，现在我也得到了我的值 2。然后现在你打印 C，对吧？所以，你知道，当你编写这样的代码时，你只是积累了许多这些功能。但是随后，你知道，当这个解释器正在运行并执行此操作时，你知道，那些功能对应于，你知道，正在运行的任务，它们可以是协程。所以它们正在运行在
same process, just, you know, in a separate, I guess, a separate thread, just to be a little more hand wavy. They could be separate threads, they, a separate thread, just to be a little more hand-wavy. They could be separate threads. They could be separate processes. They could even be on another machine. And that's one thing that really sets Julia apart. In Node.js, you can do async function, and you'll get a feature and same kind of thing. But Node.js won't actually ship that function over to another machine.
同一个进程中，只是，你知道，在一个单独的，我猜，一个单独的线程中，只是为了稍微含糊一点。它们可以是单独的线程，它们，一个单独的线程，只是为了稍微含糊一点。它们可以是单独的线程。它们可以是单独的进程。它们甚至可以在另一台机器上。这就是真正让 Julia 与众不同的地方。在 Node.js 中，你可以做异步函数，你会得到一个功能，同样的事情。但 Node.js 不会真正把那个函数发送到另一台机器上。
That's a whole different universe, right? Because, I mean, you think about the complexity there. Like, you know, for you to ship a function call to another machine, that machine has to have all of the context. You know, if that function uses a library, then that library has to exist on of the context. You know, if that function uses a library, then that library has to exist on the other machine. You know, then there's also some things that just can't happen, right?
那是一个完全不同的宇宙，对吧？因为，我的意思是，你考虑那里的复杂性。比如，你知道，为了让你把一个函数调用发送到另一台机器，那台机器必须拥有所有的上下文。你知道，如果那个函数使用了一个库，那么那个库必须存在于上下文。你知道，如果那个函数使用了一个库，那么那个库必须存在于另一台机器上。你知道，然后还有一些事情根本不可能发生，对吧？
Like if that function tries to read from disk, well, now you're kind of in trouble if you assume that it was going to be on the same machine, right? And so, you know, in Julia, there's ways to say, you know, run this asynchronously, but it has to be on my machine versus I don't care, just run it anywhere.
比如如果那个函数试图从磁盘读取，好吧，现在如果你假设它会在同一台机器上，你就有点麻烦了，对吧？所以，你知道，在 Julia 中，有办法说，你知道，异步运行这个，但它必须在我的机器上，而不是我不在乎，随便在任何地方运行它。
But the cool thing is, let's say you have some program where you're loading some images from disk, you're doing a Fourier transform, and then you're running a convolutional neural net, and then you're adding the two, and you're doing some other stuff, and you're running a convolutional neural net and then you're adding the two and you're doing some other stuff and you're calculating bounding boxes. Like you could just do all of this and Julia will farm out all of these tasks and it'll use as many resources and machines as you give it and as are allowed by the commands you're specifying.
但很酷的一点是，假设你有一个程序，需要从磁盘加载一些图像，进行傅里叶变换，然后运行卷积神经网络，接着将两者相加，再做一些其他处理，再次运行卷积神经网络，将两者相加，再做一些其他处理，最后计算边界框。你可以直接完成所有这些操作，Julia 会分发所有这些任务，并根据你给出的命令和允许的范围，尽可能多地使用资源和机器。
And then it's going to try to keep itself busy. And it's got a lot of built-in sort of pool support. So let's say you have 120 images that all need to be processed. You could just say, hey, Julia, process all 120 of these as fast as possible. And it's going to go off and do that. And so there's a lot of complexity there
然后它会尝试让自己保持忙碌。它内置了许多类似池（pool）的支持。所以，假设你有 120 张图像需要处理，你只需说：“嘿，Julia，尽快处理这 120 张图像。”它就会去执行。所以这里面隐藏了很多复杂性。
that's hidden from you. Like, for example, let's say you have 10 computers. And you tell Julia, process these 120 things as fast as possible. Julia will send the first 10 out. But then let's say the 10th one comes back first. And the other 9 are still processing. It's not going to wait for the other nine to finish. It's going to just send the 11th one to that machine that's done with the 10th one. And so it's kind of keeping track of everything for you and making sure that none of the computers
这些复杂性对你来说是透明的。例如，假设你有 10 台计算机，你告诉 Julia：“尽快处理这 120 个任务。”Julia 会先分发前 10 个。但假设第 10 个任务最先完成，而其他 9 个还在处理中，它不会等待那 9 个完成，而是会直接把第 11 个任务发送给那台已经完成第 10 个任务的机器。所以它会为你跟踪一切，确保没有计算机
are really waiting if they don't have to wait. So that's the really kind of big add. And it seems really cool. I mean, if you come from sort of a MATLAB environment where you're loading an image, that happens probably instantly, but then you're on a Fourier transform, that might take a while, or you're writing a for loop
在不必要的时候闲置等待。这就是非常大的加分项，看起来真的很棒。我的意思是，如果你来自 MATLAB 环境，加载图像可能瞬间完成，但运行傅里叶变换可能需要一段时间，或者你正在编写一个 for 循环
to loop through all these images and process them. And you go to something like Julia, where you just have this one line that says, loop through all these images and process them. And you go to something like Julia where, you know, you just have this one line that says, Hey, here's 10,000 images. Just know that's, that's really nice. Right. So, so, so you compare it to MATLAB, but one of the things about MATLAB is MATLAB is really expensive. Yeah, that's true. And so I was going was gonna say and even if you know for things that are
来遍历所有这些图像并处理它们。当你转向像 Julia 这样的语言时，你只需要一行代码就能遍历并处理所有图像。当你转向 Julia 时，你知道，你只需要写一行代码说：“嘿，这里有 10,000 张图像。”这真的很棒，对吧？所以，你把它和 MATLAB 比较，但 MATLAB 的一个问题是它非常昂贵。是的，确实如此。我本来想说，即使对于那些
free we've had this issue with java recently where uh you know oracle actually ended up winning that lawsuit and so uh yeah google is gonna have to pay oracle is like billions of dollars it's something crazy but there are some languages that they're not um or packages or whatever where they're not they're free but then they have sort of like a catch right like that they have a really restrictive license or whatever yeah although i mean i guess for java most people are probably not doing what google did um yeah i don't know the details on that so like if you just use Java is it okay I'm not a lawyer so I'm yeah that's true but let's just say that you don't have that issue in Julia because Julia is completely MIT licensed which is for people who don't know MIT and BSD are the two licenses where you know uh if you talk to a lawyer you know that
免费的东西，我们最近也遇到了 Java 的问题，你知道甲骨文（Oracle）实际上赢了那场官司，所以谷歌将不得不支付给甲骨文数十亿美元，这太疯狂了。但有些语言或包，它们虽然免费，但却有某种陷阱，比如它们有非常严格的许可协议之类的。是的，虽然我想对于 Java 来说，大多数人可能不会做谷歌那样的事。我不知道细节，所以如果你只是使用 Java，这没问题吗？我不是律师，所以我……是的，确实如此。但我们假设在 Julia 中你不会遇到这个问题，因为 Julia 完全是 MIT 许可的。对于那些不知道的人来说，MIT 和 BSD 是两种让律师感到满意的许可协议，你知道
those are the licenses that will make them smile right like if it doesn't say MIT or BSD the lawyer is going to have a lot of questions and be really nervous about using that software so so Julia is totally unencumbered so I'm I don't know if this is correct i for home use matlab even just for home use is 150 dollars for a standard license for one year presumably for a company it's 860 dollars wow that's wild i yeah, I mean, there's probably more. Like, I think at many companies, they have, like, sort of network licenses that get checked out and stuff.
这些许可协议会让律师微笑。如果它不是 MIT 或 BSD，律师会有很多疑问，并且对使用该软件感到非常紧张。所以 Julia 是完全没有负担的。我不知道这是否正确，对于家庭使用，MATLAB 即使只是家庭使用，一年标准许可也要 150 美元，想必对于公司来说是 860 美元。哇，这太疯狂了。是的，我的意思是，可能还有更多费用。我想在许多公司，他们有那种可以借出的网络许可之类的。
So maybe it's cheaper. But, I mean, that's a lot of money. Yeah, I mean, it's insane. And the open source community has, you know, caught up. I feel as if that might not be not be matlab might not have a sustainable business yeah i mean but matlab is really good to be fair like it's not like some stuff where you know oh this is some arcane package but if you really need it you'll pay the money i mean matlab it you know i don't know it's hard to say you get your money's worth when you compare
所以也许会便宜一些。但我的意思是，那是一大笔钱。是的，这太疯狂了。开源社区已经赶上来了。我觉得 MATLAB 可能没有可持续的商业模式。是的，但公平地说，MATLAB 确实很好。它不像某些东西，你知道，哦，这是一个晦涩难懂的包，但如果你真的需要它，你就会付钱。我的意思是，MATLAB，我不知道，很难说当你比较
money's worth to free that's the divide by zero thing, right? You get good support probably. You probably do. But Matlab is a really good piece of software. And I think we should be willing to pay sometimes. But if you're not going to use it a lot, it's hard to be like, I'm going to pay this money and I'm not sure if I'm going to use it. Yep. Yeah, exactly. And keep in mind,
物有所值和免费时，这就是除以零的问题，对吧？你可能会得到很好的支持。你可能确实会。但 MATLAB 确实是一个非常好的软件。我认为我们有时应该愿意付费。但如果你不经常使用它，很难说“我要付这笔钱，但我不知道我是否会用到它”。是的，完全正确。请记住，
like if you're an enterprise customer, you're invariably going to run into some problem and you're going to have millions of dollars on the line and you're going to just pay someone a lot of money to fix that problem. And so even though, so people might say, why is this free?
如果你是企业客户，你总是会遇到一些问题，并且会有数百万美元的风险，你会付给某人一大笔钱来解决这个问题。所以即使人们可能会说，为什么这是免费的？
What's the catch? Well, that's the catch, right? The catch is, you know, people might say, why is this free? What's the catch? Well, that's the catch, right? The catch is, you know, that I'm sure this company is charging for support and, you know, things like that. With that said, it's not a trap in the sense that, you know, the software is extremely professionally done, very worth, you know, the effort. But it's a bit of a question mark like with matlab i guess you pay the 800 but presumably you get some level of support for free um the forums and and you're i said go to the forums the matlab no but i mean i'm assuming if you have a license there's a phone number or something i don't know maybe i'm not maybe i'm making that up i mean i know i'm making
有什么陷阱吗？嗯，这就是陷阱，对吧？陷阱是，你知道，人们可能会说，为什么这是免费的？有什么陷阱吗？嗯，这就是陷阱，对吧？陷阱是，我相信这家公司会收取支持费用，诸如此类。话虽如此，这并不是一个陷阱，因为软件做得非常专业，非常值得投入。但这有点像个问号，比如用 MATLAB，我想你付了 800 美元，但大概你能免费获得某种程度的支持，比如论坛……我说了去论坛，MATLAB 不……但我的意思是，我假设如果你有许可，会有电话号码之类的，我不知道，也许我在编造。我的意思是，我知道我在编造
it up but maybe i'm wrong but i mean yeah i guess to point out too we've talked about this in our matlab episode but for a one-to-one replacement for matlab style stuff i guess you'd probably consider octave so julia isn't going to be a drop-in one-to-one replacement but for the style of work that is often done in matlab that, that would be where you consider Julia. Yep. Yeah, exactly. In terms of like, you know, one of the hesitations using Julia might be that it doesn't necessarily have so much support in terms of library. Like, for example, let's say you need to load, I don't know, some geospatial data that's in some GIS custom format or something like that. Or you need protocol buffers or I don't know, whatever, right? You know, you might say, well, you know, I'm taking a risk using a language
但我可能是错的。但我的意思是，是的，我想指出的是，我们在 MATLAB 那一期节目中讨论过，对于 MATLAB 风格的东西的直接替代品，我想你可能会考虑 Octave。所以 Julia 不会是一个直接的、一对一的替代品，但对于通常在 MATLAB 中完成的工作类型，那才是你会考虑 Julia 的地方。是的，完全正确。就比如，使用 Julia 的一个顾虑可能是它在库方面的支持不一定那么多。例如，假设你需要加载一些 GIS 自定义格式的地理空间数据，或者你需要协议缓冲区（protocol buffers），或者我不知道，诸如此类，对吧？你可能会说，好吧，我使用像
like Julia because it's not going to support something I really need. They do have a JuliaPy library, which lets you run Python code inside of Julia. It is pretty good. It actually, they wrote a bunch of logic there to handle NumPy arrays. So if you create a NumPy array in Python, you know, as part of some process, part of this JuliaPy process, and they need to bring that back to Julia, they'll actually just do a pointer assignment. They're not going to actually copy it. Actually, I think they, yeah, if you create a NumPy array using the PyData or the JuliaPyData object, so there's a little bit of some stuff you have to do
Julia 这样的语言是在冒险，因为它不支持我真正需要的东西。他们有一个 JuliaPy 库，允许你在 Julia 中运行 Python 代码。它相当不错。实际上，他们编写了一堆逻辑来处理 NumPy 数组。所以如果你在 Python 中创建了一个 NumPy 数组，作为某个过程的一部分，作为这个 JuliaPy 过程的一部分，并且他们需要把它带回 Julia，他们实际上只会做一个指针赋值。他们不会真正复制它。实际上，我想他们……是的，如果你使用 PyData 或 JuliaPyData 对象创建 NumPy 数组，所以你必须做一些
that's a little bit special. But basically, it's very performant. object. So there's a little bit of some stuff you have to do that's a little bit special. But basically, it's very performant. You can call into Python if you need to. And that shouldn't stop you from trying it out. So one of the cool things that I found about Julia was that there are only four languages, four high-level languages that have ever been used to write computer programs that executed at greater than one petaflop sort of compute power.
稍微特殊的事情。但基本上，它的性能非常高。你可以根据需要调用 Python。这不应该阻止你尝试它。所以我发现 Julia 的一件很酷的事情是，历史上只有四种高级语言被用于编写在超过一千万亿次浮点运算（petaflop）计算能力下执行的计算机程序。
And so those are C, C++, Fortran, and Julia. So those are pretty good accomplishment. And you were talking about the, you know, support for distributed messaging and working and that kind of stuff and right that i mean this is sort of evidence of that that that you know isn't every language that you would use in such an environment and one day i guess everybody will have a petaflop under their desk um yeah but but that day is not today um and it was interesting that i would have thought the number of languages would have been higher. But at least according to Wikipedia, this is, yeah, it's only four languages, four don't have an intuition as to how flops relates to, like, megahertz or gigahertz.
它们是 C、C++、Fortran 和 Julia。所以这些是相当不错的成就。你刚才谈到了对分布式消息传递和工作等方面的支持，这确实是证据，证明了并不是每种语言都能在这样的环境中使用。我想总有一天每个人桌子上都会有一台千万亿次浮点运算能力的计算机。是的，但那一天不是今天。有趣的是，我原以为语言的数量会更多。但至少根据维基百科，是的，只有四种语言。四种……我对浮点运算（flops）与兆赫（megahertz）或吉赫（gigahertz）的关系没有直觉。
So, like, can you put it in? So, sure. Okay. I wasn't ready for this. Flops is floating point operations per second. So, a petaflop is 10 to the 15 floating point operations in one second. So that is, if you think about... That's a million gigaflops, is that right?
所以，你能解释一下吗？当然，好的。我没准备好这个。Flops 是每秒浮点运算次数。所以一千万亿次浮点运算（petaflop）就是每秒 10 的 15 次方次浮点运算。所以如果你考虑……那是 100 万个吉赫（gigaflops），对吗？
Gigaflop is 10 to the 9, a million gigaflops, yes. Yeah, okay. So if you think of a gigahertz computer as doing that many instructions, and if you can assume that you do like a flop in one hertz, then this would be a million gigahertz. I didn't follow that math. Something like that. But I mean, the idea is that each,
吉赫（Gigaflop）是 10 的 9 次方，100 万个吉赫，是的。是的，好的。所以如果你认为一台吉赫（gigahertz）计算机执行那么多指令，并且如果你假设你在 1 赫兹内执行一次浮点运算，那么这将是 100 万个吉赫。我没跟上那个数学。类似那样。但我的意思是，想法是每个
so floating point operations can take longer and often do take longer than integer calculations so in your computer's alu right you might be able to say i want to increase this number by one and for an integer that's straightforward like there are literal like gates that just execute that not instantaneously but within one clock cycle and handle the results but to increase a floating point number by integer value of one you can't just sort of directly manipulate some bits like the amount of logic you need to do for the various parts of the floating point number uh mean that it takes a little longer often. So depending on your architecture and the exact computers,
浮点运算可能比整数计算花费更长的时间，而且通常确实花费更长的时间。在计算机的算术逻辑单元（ALU）中，你可能可以说我想把这个数字增加 1，对于整数来说这很简单，就像有字面意义上的门电路直接执行它，不是瞬间完成，但在一个时钟周期内完成并处理结果。但要将一个浮点数增加 1，你不能只是直接操作一些位，因为你需要为浮点数的各个部分执行的逻辑量意味着它通常需要更长的时间。所以根据你的架构和具体的计算机，
and this is why you have things like high-performance computer clusters that often, not always, but often run different hardware or might run certain kinds of processors that are different, is because of this ability to focus on floating-point operations. So if you're doing something like computational fluid dynamics, where you're say, modeling how air flows over an airplane wing, and you're trying to understand
这就是为什么你有高性能计算机集群，它们通常（不是总是，但通常）运行不同的硬件或可能运行某些不同种类的处理器，这是因为能够专注于浮点运算。所以如果你在做计算流体动力学之类的事情，比如模拟空气如何流过飞机机翼，并且你试图理解
where there's turbulence being generated. And so you're sort of figuring out how air molecules move around roughly, right? Then you're doing all of this with floating point numbers, and you need to do a lot of them because there are many, many, many things to be evaluated all at one time. And so that's where having these supercomputer clusters
湍流在哪里产生。所以你大致是在计算空气分子是如何移动的，对吧？然后你用浮点数做所有这些，你需要做很多，因为有很多很多东西需要同时评估。这就是拥有这些超级计算机集群的地方
measured in petaflops is they're basically running one gigantic distributed computation that is like, this isn't exactly right, but imagine if you were going to actually simulate every air molecule right so the simulation wants to advance one millisecond and you need to for every air molecule in the volume of interest you need to figure out where that air molecule would go would it bounce off of an object would it bounce off of another air molecule in this you know sort
以千万亿次浮点运算来衡量，它们基本上是在运行一个巨大的分布式计算，这不完全准确，但想象一下如果你要真正模拟每一个空气分子，那么模拟想要推进一毫秒，你需要为感兴趣体积内的每一个空气分子计算出那个空气分子会去哪里，它会从物体上反弹吗？它会从另一个空气分子上反弹吗？在这个（你知道）
of one millisecond interval and do that for every air molecule and then you update now you have the new state and now you need to keep doing that except when you bump into another air molecule you sort of have this cascade effect it's very complicated right so if you that's a sort of contrived example that's not how they do it but if you sort of think about that if you were running a simulation that did that that would be enormously computationally and expensive and so when you have these things measured in petaflops the supercomputers some things, you can let them run really long, but if you're trying to do weather forecasting, if it takes you five days to forecast what the weather's going to be tomorrow,
一毫秒的间隔内，为每一个空气分子做这件事，然后你更新，现在你有了一个新的状态，现在你需要继续这样做，除了当你撞到另一个空气分子时，你会有这种级联效应，这非常复杂，对吧？所以如果你……这是一个人为的例子，这不是他们做的方式，但如果你这样想，如果你运行一个那样的模拟，那将是巨大的计算量和昂贵的。所以当你拥有这些以千万亿次浮点运算衡量的超级计算机时，有些事情你可以让它们运行很长时间，但如果你试图做天气预报，如果你需要五天时间来预测明天的天气，
that's actually not useful. I mean, I guess it kind of is useful, but it's not useful for forecasting. No, it makes sense. I guess the thing I'm not sure about is if Julia is C++ and C under the hood, then like, does it count? Wait, but it's not C++. What do you mean by under the hood? So in other words, like the Julia operations, I mean, you know, obviously the farming to other machines and things like that are written in Julia or maybe written in some high level language. But under the hood the thing is doing the computation it's still calling to some blaz library or something i mean it's
那实际上没有用。我的意思是，我想它确实有点用，但对预报来说没用。不，这说得通。我想我不确定的是，如果 Julia 在底层是 C++ 和 C，那么它算数吗？等等，但它不是 C++。你说的“底层”是什么意思？所以换句话说，比如 Julia 的操作，我的意思是，你知道，显然分发到其他机器之类的事情是用 Julia 编写的，或者可能是用某种高级语言编写的。但在底层，做计算的东西仍然在调用一些 BLAS 库之类的，我的意思是它
ultimately calling machine code right but the the program itself the thing that is doing the high that is it's not scripting but doing the high level hooking together of all of the pieces is written in julia i think is what they're trying to say but i guess my question is why isn't every language on that list because with any language that has a c++ binding you could use you could run this the the the code really fast because you wouldn't actually be running i don't know java code you'd be running c++ just called from java you know what i mean no but that's not i mean you're i guess it is the difference between libraries calling a library and your
最终调用的是机器码，对吧？但程序本身，那个做高……它不是脚本，而是做所有部分的高级连接的东西是用 Julia 编写的，我想这就是他们想表达的意思。但我猜我的问题是，为什么不是每种语言都在那个列表上？因为对于任何有 C++ 绑定的语言，你都可以使用它，你可以让代码运行得非常快，因为你实际上不会运行，我不知道，Java 代码，你运行的是从 Java 调用的 C++，你知道我的意思吗？不，但那不是……我的意思是，我想这就是库调用库和你
actual code so sure if you wrote one big library that was do really complex math for my problem in its totality and all I did was write a Java program that said call library, do my gigantic program. Yes, you could do that. Sure. Well, I guess maybe another way of saying it is
实际代码之间的区别。所以当然，如果你写了一个大库，它为我的问题整体做了非常复杂的数学运算，而我所做的只是写了一个 Java 程序，说调用库，做我的巨大程序。是的，你可以那样做。当然。好吧，我想也许另一种说法是
why isn't MATLAB on this list? Because nobody, that's what I'm saying because nobody describes the computations in MATLAB for this list? Because nobody, that's what I'm saying, because nobody describes the computations in MATLAB for supercomputers that run at that scale or hasn't according to this thing. Oh, I see. Because it's so big that it's really a distributed.
为什么 MATLAB 不在这个列表上？因为没有人……这就是我说的，因为没有人为这个列表描述 MATLAB 中的计算？因为没有人……这就是我说的，因为没有人为在这个规模上运行的超级计算机描述 MATLAB 中的计算，或者根据这个东西还没有。哦，我明白了。因为它太大了，所以它真的是一个分布式的。
That's right. So there's no single machine that has 1.5. So it's a whole bunch of things, right? And so MATLAB has no like, or at least not built-in TCP support. Right, if you wanted to do it in Java, you're going to have to, like, well, I mean, again, if you're not going to do it in a sort of hacky cheat way, you would need Java to handle all of the networking communication back and forth.
没错。所以没有单台机器拥有 1.5。所以它是一大堆东西，对吧？所以 MATLAB 没有类似的东西，或者至少没有内置的 TCP 支持。对，如果你想用 Java 做这件事，你将不得不……好吧，我的意思是，同样，如果你不打算用那种黑客式的作弊方式，你需要 Java 来处理所有来回的网络通信。
You would have to have it doing the computation. Sure, at the lowest level, you say, like, transpose this matrix. Maybe it runs machine code that originally came from C++. But, I mean, so does everything else, right? Right, I guess. But the reason why they're not all on this list is because of the distributed part. Well, because of the distributed part and the complexity of the calculations and the suitability for it. Yeah, like, presumably, you know,
你必须让它做计算。当然，在最低层，你说，比如转置这个矩阵。也许它运行的是最初来自 C++ 的机器码。但我的意思是，其他所有东西也是这样，对吧？对，我想是这样。但它们不在这个列表上的原因是分布式部分。嗯，因为分布式部分和计算的复杂性以及对它的适用性。是的，比如，大概，你知道，
let's say you want to invert a huge matrix, right? So to invert a huge matrix, it's kind of complicated. Like you have to give entire rows and entire columns to certain machines of the matrix. And it could be that doing that is so slow when it's Java calling into C++ or whatever, that just doesn't work. And you can only really do that in Julia or by writing the whole thing in PRC.
假设你想反转一个巨大的矩阵，对吧？所以反转一个巨大的矩阵，它有点复杂。比如你必须把整个行和整个列给矩阵的某些机器。而且可能是这样做在 Java 调用 C++ 或其他什么时太慢了，以至于根本行不通。你真的只能在 Julia 中或者通过用 C 编写整个东西来做到这一点。
Because you have to take a row of a matrix and memcopy it into a TCP buffer, and that's just not possible in java right yeah that's i so yeah that makes sense so basically if you want to do distributed high performance computing and it's not embarrassingly parallel because if it's you know if if you need to invert 10 million small matrices or a billion small matrices, you could achieve 1.5 petaflops. Like you would just give a small matrix to each machine and you just do this with as many machines as you need to get 1.5 petaflops.
因为你必须取矩阵的一行并将其内存复制（memcopy）到 TCP 缓冲区中，而这在 Java 中是不可能的，对吧？是的，这……所以是的，这说得通。所以基本上，如果你想做分布式高性能计算，而且它不是尴尬地并行（embarrassingly parallel），因为如果它是……你知道，如果你需要反转 1000 万个小矩阵或 10 亿个小矩阵，你可以达到 1.5 千万亿次浮点运算。就像你会给每台机器一个小矩阵，你只需要用尽可能多的机器来达到 1.5 千万亿次浮点运算。
But the issue is if you need to invert one huge matrix and it's going to take 1.5 petaflops to do that and all the data is kind of dependent on each other in weird ways then you're pretty much either writing julia or you're writing low levels yeah and i mean i guess the thing is to these machines the the computers i mean we look at the supercomputer list the supercomputers are very expensive to to build and so you're not going to just run, you know,
但问题是，如果你需要反转一个巨大的矩阵，并且需要 1.5 千万亿次浮点运算来做这件事，而且所有数据都以奇怪的方式相互依赖，那么你基本上要么在写 Julia，要么在写底层代码。是的，我的意思是，我想事情是这样的，这些机器，计算机……我的意思是，我们看超级计算机列表，超级计算机建造起来非常昂贵，所以你不会只是运行，你知道，
haha, cheeky, I want to get Java on the list. I mean, I guess they could. If someone cared enough to do it, they probably could write for any language, right? But the point is, these are typically used
哈哈，厚脸皮，我想把 Java 列入名单。我的意思是，我想他们可以。如果有人足够关心去做这件事，他们可能可以为任何语言编写，对吧？但重点是，这些通常被用于
for real processing that makes money or government is paying for or research or something because, you know, they need to be doing that and so yeah to spend the time and effort to develop for these highly customized systems you would want to know that you were going to get value out of it yeah yeah totally so i'm looking it looks like there are 305 in the whole entire world systems that run at a petaflop.
真正的处理，赚钱的，或者政府付费的，或者研究之类的，因为，你知道，他们需要做这些，所以是的，花时间和精力为这些高度定制的系统开发，你会想知道你将从中获得价值。是的，是的，完全正确。所以我看了一下，看起来全世界总共有 305 个系统运行在千万亿次浮点运算级别。
You mean clusters or just? Yeah, clusters. Oh, okay. So. Wow. Wait, you think that's high or low? No, no. I think, I mean, yeah i i think that that sounds reasonable so it is just
你是说集群还是仅仅？是的，集群。哦，好的。所以。哇。等等，你认为这很高还是很低？不，不。我想，我的意思是，是的，我认为这听起来很合理，所以它只是
the 305th highest ranked so i went to the top supercomputer ranking list uh and i guess these are ones that are disclosed right so something like uh uh some uh uber data center not on uber maybe twitter data center or whatever maybe has some and it's not disclosed and it's not really set up but i don't think yeah i was gonna say i don't think those cali you could say aws is the most powerful cluster in the world and i mean technically yes except it's not like a coordinated cluster so so the 300 so i went to the i just scrolled down the sorted list until i found the last one that is still above a thousand teraflops and that is the 305th one and that one has 27 608 cores wow it takes 27 608 2.4 gigahertz xeon cores to get that performance. 26,000. 27,000.
第 305 位排名最高的，所以我去了顶级超级计算机排名列表，我想这些是披露出来的，对吧？所以像……一些优步（Uber）数据中心，也许不是优步，可能是推特（Twitter）数据中心之类的，也许有一些，但没有披露，也没有真正设置好，但我认为……是的，我本来想说，我不认为那些……你可以说 AWS 是世界上最强大的集群，我的意思是技术上是的，除了它不像一个协调的集群。所以……第 300……所以我去了……我只是向下滚动排序列表，直到找到最后一个仍然超过 1000 万亿次浮点运算（teraflops）的，那是第 305 个，那个有 27,608 个核心。哇，需要 27,608 个 2.4 GHz 的至强（Xeon）核心才能获得那种性能。26,000。27,000。
27,000. Now in theory, because these are only 2.4 gigahertz xeons, in theory, you could probably have less cores. Oh, so here's one. So there are some on here with newer hardware that have only like 17,000 cores. That's still unbelievable. Here's one with 15 000 cores if each board has 64 cores i don't have my calculator up yeah let's just say each board has a hundred cores that's still a lot of machines right i mean that's 1700 machines yes
27,000。现在理论上，因为这些只是 2.4 GHz 的至强，理论上，你可能可以有更少的核心。哦，这里有一个。所以这里有一些使用更新硬件的，只有大约 17,000 个核心。那仍然令人难以置信。这里有一个有 15,000 个核心的，如果每个板子有 64 个核心……我没打开计算器……是的，我们假设每个板子有 100 个核心，那仍然有很多机器，对吧？我的意思是那是 1700 台机器。是的，
if i'm reading this list right yeah Some of these have 100,000 cores, yes. Wow, that's wild. But the lowest one I saw was sort of like 15,000 cores to get a petaflop. Yeah, so Julia works at... We're off on a tangent now. Yeah. But yeah, it's cool. It's compiled, which nowadays I think most things are compiled.
如果我没读错这个列表的话。是的，其中一些有 100,000 个核心，是的。哇，这太疯狂了。但我看到的最低的一个大约是 15,000 个核心才能达到千万亿次浮点运算。是的，所以 Julia 工作在……我们现在跑题了。是的。但是的，这很酷。它是编译型的，现在我想大多数东西都是编译型的。
Like even MATLAB, I think it compiles it the first time you run it. Like Python has the PYC files. But they're still going to be pretty slow. But Julia, you know, it must compile down pretty quickly. You can tell they spent a lot of time on making it really fast. Yeah, and so I think it sounds pretty cool. I'll definitely try it out, you know, start using it for something and see how it goes. I'll report back.
就像 MATLAB，我想它在你第一次运行它时就编译了。就像 Python 有 PYC 文件。但它们仍然会相当慢。但 Julia，你知道，它一定编译得相当快。你可以看出他们花了很多时间让它变得非常快。是的，所以我认为这听起来很酷。我肯定会尝试一下，你知道，开始用它做点什么，看看效果如何。我会回来报告的。
All right. Until next time. Cool. Have a good one the intro music is axo by biner pilot programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy distribute transmit the work to remix adapt the work but you must provide attribution to patrick and i and share alike in kind There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
好的。下次见。酷。祝你过得愉快。片头音乐是 Biner Pilot 的 Axo。Programming Throwdown 是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下分发的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输该作品，以重混、改编该作品，但你必须向 Patrick 和我提供署名，并以相同方式共享。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。